première journée et je vais cadrer ta
caméra j'espère que tu vas bien ça va
très très bien je pète la forme elle
était en grande forme Mathieu pas de pas
de souci de santé aujourd'hui non ça va
ça va c'est ta grande ta grande journée
alors attends je vais essayer de
t'afficher le plus rapidement possible
il y a aussi les joueurs qui sont en
train d'arriver donc c'est un peu le
rush de la première ronde c'est la le le
quart de finale c'est le dès que
quelqu'un arrive ça décale toutes les
caméras ou pas alors je sais pas parce
que pour cette année Mathieu il y a un
nouveau programme qui est utilisé un
nouveau logiciel que je n'ai absolument
jamais utilisé de ma vie mais ça a l'air
pas mal fait donc je pense que ça va
être bien
de toute façon les gens vont le
reconnaître puisqu'ils vont le voir donc
mais c'est teams ouais je l'utilise des
fois moi pour mes cours et tu vois moi
ça va être la première fois que je que
je vais là plutôt bien fait moi je suis
pas du tout spécialiste mais
que ça faisait bien le taf tu as vu je
me suis mis un petit col je sais pas
comment ça s'appelle la dans le chat
peut me dire l'école comme ça là
un col roulé
j'aime bien c'est nouveau alors pour
l'instant
pour moi il y a pas écrit quelque chose
comme effet et live ah ça y est ça va ça
va ça va se lancer Matthieu donc par
rapport au spectateur on va voir une
petite minute de décalage normalement
donc excusez-nous si on n'est pas mais
du coup ceux qui regardent les parties
en la vie aussi
alors ouais en fait moi moi je vais
pouvoir les voir en live mais parce que
c'est fait en sorte que je puisse mais
il y a que moi qui peut c'est pour ça
que tu dois suivre avec mon partage
d'écran Mathieu parce que toi tu ne veux
pas aller suivre
tu peux pas être plus live que moi en
fait
je suis en galère tu vois que je suis en
galère parce que ça se voit
non
par contre là où je suis en fait je suis
vraiment
sur sur la conversation est beaucoup
plus en réalité je suis pour
ah oui je fais réclavic open avec Mazo
Libye on est dans on a un beau trio
que le cheminée peut-être c'est joli
très bien team franchement moi
je commence à avoir des joueurs mais le
truc c'est que
il y en a qui disent qu'il y a une
minute de délai sur le chat
en fait il y a toutes les caméras sauf
celle
qui t'intéresse
ah mais la connexion à Chartres elle est
pas très bonne
mais il est plus vraiment à charge je
crois qu'il est plus à Paris maintenant
il a les deux je crois
qu'il est quand même
mais ouais alors attends c'est
et j'en profite pour le dire donc
Mathieu je l'ai pas encore dit pendant
qu'on attend l'arrivée des joueurs que
le tournoi est sponsorisé par par
rcmaster c'est d'ailleurs le RC master
montrer comme tout
je vais la voir mais je le montrerai
peut-être demain parce que je serai avec
Fab du coup on sera côte à côte et on
pourra voir le prototype et je pourrais
le montrer du coup avec Fab en duo
au studio
si tu peux le décaler tu peux je suis
très très bien je suis très très bien
Mathieu je crois qu'on a
risque pour le partage de fichiers team
c'est pas terrible mais sinon c'est très
bien
non non mais ça a l'air ça a l'air très
très bien c'est juste que la caméra
d'aliérésa c'est un écran noir donc en
fait on voit les afficher mais en écran
noir je vais pouvoir vous récupérer
regaizi déjà
si ça vous fait un champion mon champion
qui a mal alors tu vas d'ailleurs nous
expliquer un truc comment on se qualifie
pour ce temps là il y avait des
qualifire que tu aurais pu jouer
d'ailleurs qui se jouait vendredi donc
il y a tous les grands maîtres avaient
le droit de participer et après il y a
pas eu des comment ça s'est fait après
il y a eu des après en fait non en fait
c'était pas si compliqué si tu étais
dans les 12 premiers tu avais un match
tu avais un match de playoff pour
savoir si tu si tu qualifiais ou pas en
fait d'accord et moi j'ai vu par mon
second cash qui avait gagné l'Open en
plus une sorte d'Open et après il jouait
cramique et après j'ai pas vu j'ai pas
trouvé où voir les parties alors trouvez
voir les parties ça je sais pas mais ce
que je peux te dire c'est que il a
et en fait la seule vraie surprise
les azéries ont toujours surtout sur
internet mais moi je le connais très
bien c'est un coéquipier de ma femme et
il est hyper sympa
attends je peux porter sur la boisson
mais je comprends pas comment je dois
mettre les caméras en fait ce que j'ai
pas pu faire de test évidemment parce
que les joueurs étaient pas là et je
comprends pas comment ça fonctionne ah
mais tu te vois plus le nom c'est ça
ou alors tu dois te déformer non mais
déformer c'est bizarre mais en fait ça
fait des carrés qui doivent être fait
comme ça en fait
j'arrive pas trop à comprendre bah il y
a Ludwig qui va me dire mais le truc
c'est qu'il a un décalage
j'arrive pas à comprendre en fait
si elle est bloquée sa caméra non
non il bouge pas il bouge pas
très bon ah oui ah oui il a une minute
de décalage
en fait je peux faire
et du coup pour
assis comme ça ouais mais c'est un peu
con donc
au milieu et tu décales les côtés mais
c'est moche
mais tu peux pas faire ça baisser le bas
et écarter
et comme ça c'est moche
son nom et son nom et sur son pull blanc
faudrait le mettre
ouais non c'est fait pour être en petit
je crois mais c'est horrible en fait
tu veux que j'aille voir les concurrents
les concurrents non les autres langues
en fait là il y a plus de concurrence on
est tout est à nous là maintenant
Mathieu
concurrence c'est terrible en fait tu te
rappelles le meilleur moment de la
chaîne c'est quand on est passé devant
tout court non ouais c'était cool ça
c'est pas trop en fait
alors
je vais pas la mettre en petit comme ça
c'est débile et en fait
ils prennent plus le côté mais ils ont
mis que Carlson donc et Sarah quoi mais
ils le mettent quoi il le mette en très
grand ouais en très grand et le nom il
le met comment en dessous alors ils
prennent le nom là ils le mettent en
dessous
tu veux que je t'envoie une photo du
truc que je vois
mais le derrière le bandeau gris
envoyez comment ils sont les ricains
soit on le voit plus du tout en fait le
bandeau gris il est forcément au-dessus
et tu peux pas baisser pourquoi il y a
un bandeau gris en dessous ah c'est pour
le E c'est directement en bas le
furogène est trop
tu veux dire que le nom il est tout en
bas le nom pour eux
et le bandeau il y est ou pas il y a pas
de bandeau en dessous
ok donc
il est écrit dans le bandeau gris
donc là en fait il faudrait que tu
baisses
je comprends pas
ah bah ouais ils ont pas du tout la même
chose que moi c'est beaucoup mieux ce
qu'ils ont
et ouais bah oui c'est logique ce qu'ils
ont pourquoi moi j'ai pas la même chose
là toi tu as un truc qui sert à rien qui
te fait perdre de l'espace qui est
complètement au milieu
je suis d'accord mais le nom est mal
placé
c'est quelqu'un qui t'a fait la config
c'est ça
non mais on a récupéré la config on l'a
fait avec Ludwig ce matin mais au pire
ce que je vais faire c'est que en fait
je vais récupérer le nom et puis je vais
le mettre là en fait non
je vais faire comme ça mais c'est un peu
moins beau que ça aurait pu l'être
ouais tu décales un peu tu le mets un
peu plus de comme ça
c'est dégueulasse mais non mais en fait
faut dire que chez lui c'est pas très
beau ça c'est pas trop de ta faute non
mais genre en fait l'espace caméra il
rentrait pile quoi
pour Magnus tu vois tu vois une chambre
entière avec
un truc sur le mur ah mais du coup les
gens vont voient les coups une minute
avant le début de la partie pour nous
non ils peuvent pas parce que moi j'ai
un compte spécial qui fait que moi je
les ai
il faut que tu remontes
comme ça ça va
non en fait pour t'expliquer si tu te
connectes à chaise en fait enfin où que
tu te connectes tu auras les coups une
minute après moi simplement moi j'ai les
coups en direct mais toi tu peux pas les
avoir sers-toi si tu te connectes sur
chaise tu as une minute de retard aussi
non mais Luigi qui a fait les trucs
parfaitement c'est juste qu'on avait le
truc pour que ce soit fait comme ça mais
quand on regarde en fait c'est bête de
mettre la caméra en tout petit et
d'avoir le bandeau du nom en grand et
comme il s'appelle il est il est à New
York Magnus je pense il est avec
ericanson il y a comme ça on essaie de
faire un truc sur l'ordi il y a
peut-être un problème
il y a pas la caméra donc actuellement
il peut pas jouer non non là je pense
pas que ça enfin si ça joue sur étonné
parce que c'est son nom en prévision
ouais je peux c'est pas con
que même dans la dessus ça sera toujours
plus joli d'avoir le bandeau au milieu
c'est bizarre
après il y a quelqu'un qui dit qu'on
peut mettre en fait le nom aussi ici
éventuellement
ouais mais là regarde c'est pas con il
est pas con regarde on le met une avec
le temps mais tu veux et du coup tu
descends ça
fondamentalement c'est pas mal comme ça
ouais il a raison en fait pas mal en
vrai tard il a raison le frérot non mais
après on est une mine de retard féroja
il faut l'écrire en noir du coup
alors il aura les blancs
ou alors on fait comme ils veulent
il avait quand même ça ne marche pas
le taper noir tu peux changer la typo
ouais
je pense on fait comme ça ça c'est plus
beau quoi
ça intéresse par contre la la pendule
dit n'importe quoi non c'est ta dernière
partie mais c'est pour que mais comme ça
on sait qu'elles sont bien cadrées sinon
on aurait pas eu de pendule donc ça
c'est plutôt cool
donc ils ont déjà dit
c'est ça le problème c'est que le
bandeau il est il est dans le dans le
PNG donc ça fait qu'en fait il devrait
servir à passer dessous sauf qu'il peut
pas passer dessous donc en fait ouais
c'est un bandeau crée un problème en
fait
il aurait dû être
aimé faire dans le chat c'est toi non
non c'est pas moi c'est soit Nathan soit
Sami bonjour
ouais ben de toute façon là ça ne peut
pas commencer
alors il y a des gens déjà qui ont
commencé dans les autres divisions
ah non je crois que ça commence un peu
parce qu'il y a ça doit ni qui joue bon
de toute façon nous on va attendre 6
tu veux pas changer la scène c'est ça
ouais bon là on a tout fait
si on commence à changer enfin tu vois
la galère que c'était si ça prend dans
30 secondes mais là il y a des parties
qui commencent de partout donc ça
devrait commencer après je voyais Karou
qui s'énerve un peu là
il est hyper énervé car mais je crois
qu'il a perdu sa grand-mère hier
d'après ce que j'ai compris donc ouais
je
[Musique]
t'ai d'autant plus saoulé s'il y a des
problèmes
c'est vrai qu'il y a des divisions en
dessous qui jouent
je suis pas sûr que ce soit sa
grand-mère ou quoi mais je crois qu'il a
perdu quelqu'un de sa famille hier donc
ouais donc firuja ça joue mais il y a
pas sa caméra alors
division 40000
attends je vais je vais écrire parce que
la caméra donc je vais devoir écrire
[Musique]
il a dû se faire éliminer de la division
temps j'écris juste un truc donc ça a
commencé
ah ça doit être Nathan réponds
en tout cas j'ai écrit on va essayer
d'avoir d'avoir l'info
non mais la confit que tu as fait là
elle est pas dégueu oui non mais là je
demande juste pour pour la salle
question que j'ai c'est la lame de
[Musique]
de filou en fait le reste ça va
B4 ici ouais c'est la sonde de coups
c'est intéressant parce qu'en fait ici
il faut baisser pas être le meilleur
c'est censé aller plutôt en
[Musique]
le 7 ici
on ne demande pas pourquoi c'est juste
que ce que j'avais à ce que j'avais
appris quand j'étais petit
donc
1819 c'est son élo en quoi en rapide je
suppose
je crois que c'est un rapide
donc
il connaît très bien ces Italiens on se
rappelle un sa victoire contre
PAM contrat rognan juste après les
candidats il avait sorti une prépa
mvl joue pas du tout ça je crois pas non
après après vu que c'est le la série de
Tournon il y a le plus d'argent de
l'année Mathieu je pense qu'il jouera
après est-ce que tu veux qu'on fasse un
point qualité de l'air ou pas est-ce que
est-ce qu'on a de la qualité de l'air
quelque part
comment ça marche alors attends
le jeu de la fenêtre
je peux te dire chez firuja on l'a pas
mais chez Guiri chez Guiri
non si ça va qualité quality faire 53 %
d'humidité 21 degrés bon il y a quand
même beaucoup de CO2 chez guéri
oh tu veux que je dise c'est Daniel la
ranch
c'est beau
tu vois il te disent si tu respires
mieux tu joueras mieux
c'est pas mal ça que tu peux voir ça
ouais c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
que les parties tu vois je suis très
heureux je suis très déçu qu'on est pas
suffisant si quelqu'un peut me trouver
le lien il me l'envoyer sur messenger
côté de chats comme ce serait cool parce
qu'on pourrait voir de la qualité de
l'air oui c'est magnifique en fait en
fait c'est trop ouais c'est beau ah ça
me fait hyper plaisir et du coup ça si
tu veux tu peux le brancher chez toi tu
peux connecter le boîtier R6
et partager avec ta famille ta qualité
de l'air en direct si tu as envie tu es
pas obligé mais tu peux et ça te fait
gagner 100 points
beaucoup plus moi je pense que si j'ai
pas de mineurs sur chescom c'est parce
que ouais j'ai peut-être trop d'humidité
ouais c'est extraordinaire c'est pas une
blague à tout moment en fait on commence
les qualités d'air on peut j'essaierai
là pour demain aujourd'hui on a essayé
de faire un truc qui marche déjà mais
pour demain ça peut à tout moment
essayer d'avoir
tous les airs de tout le monde on peut
on peut voir un peu ça l'air d'Erika ici
en Inde l'air est pas ouf
bonjour
j'ai vu hier chez lui moi je regarde un
peu les qualités d'air forcément chez
visite il faisait 25 degrés hier il
était pour ave il y avait un rouge quoi
il doit pas être bien vite
bon c'est une italienne ou un moment ça
va s'échanger en E4 et ça va être assez
solide mais la question c'est est-ce
qu'il peut payer ce milieu de jeu ou il
est un peu plus d'espace et puis on le
sent qui est sur 15 mois
on va voir un match de toute façon là il
y a les raisins qui réfléchit est-ce que
c'est vraiment lui qui joue tu penses
son frère j'ai joué contre son frère
mercredi
donc comme ça j'étais pas bien j'avais
une pièce de moins puis je l'ai arnaqué
en dessous de ppm moi je sais même pas
ce que c'est je suis désolé tu peux me
dire moi non plus mais je suis à deux
doigts de mettre la qualité de l'air en
dessous en permanence pendant live
franchement ça t'a rien
je pense le faire
j'ai une question Julius bar c'est quoi
par contre tu perds les caméras quand tu
fais ça ça c'est parce que je les ai pas
mises partout parce qu'on a pas pu setup
tout le truc ce matin parce qu'on
n'avait pas les les je peux que le
mettre si tu veux
il n'y a pas l'air de faire le Gange
depuis hier
à mon avis tu sais quoi il est il est à
l'hôtel
mais il fait quand même chaud chez lui
ouais mais ça c'est pas de sa faute non
en fait de mettre le l'appareil dans un
endroit où tu habites pas du tout pour
faire croire aux autres que tu as une
mauvaise qualité d'air alors que tu es
très très bien quoi tu m'offres
humide alors il y a des joueurs un peu
au hasard il y a grand délice
c'est pas terrible
bah ouais il est un peu trop de ces
particules par mètre cube CO2 par mètre
cube peut-être particules par mignon
partie par mignon un particulier
en fait il a pas connecté son truc donc
on n'a pas son air
Mélanie sac à ma vie
il fait très sec chez lui
il fait chaud dans son appart 24 il
habite où
il était pas aux États-Unis à l'époque
où les revenus
où il fait chaud
c'est marrant ce truc
là c'est son nouveau sponsor
qui est aussi un des sponsors du tournoi
tu vas le voir sur la petite rotation tu
as des trucs un peu sympa tu as tué
Sarah je les connais pas tous chez
sarama c'est un jeu qui sort
je crois qui est codé par des Brésiliens
si je dis pas de bêtises qui a l'air
assez cool
et Julius c'est quoi et Julius ça doit
être j'ai pas envie de dire de bêtises
faut que je regarde j'ai j'ai eu su je
pense que je sais mais je vais pas dire
de bêtises chez sable tu connais
ça
je suis très heureux en fait ça va être
très dur de commenter les parties il y a
trop de sponsors en fait ça nous fait
trop de ouais bon entre l'air le machin
je sais pas c'est sarama enfin on peut
plus en fait
mais firou il a ni la cam ni le capteur
ouais firou c'est on sait même pas on
n'a pas Saka mais on sait pas quel est
l'air qu'il a chez lui
en tout cas c'est beau bon il se passe
pas grand chose dans la partie
il a la Webster University ouais ben il
fait pas il fait pas froid là-bas je
pense qu'il est à New York
il chauffe trop chez lui un pas très
écologique du coup il est pas chez lui
il est chez des
non mais les
allez chez qui faisait chaud
parce qu'il est le chef il a remplacé
Suzan
là-bas il fait trop chaud
privé
mais je n'étais pas sûr
en tout cas je suis super heureux là
ce sont les sponsors
du tournoi en directement là
que ton nom qui s'appelle
[Musique]
management
en tout cas la position est plutôt
équilibrée pour le moment ok jouer parce
qu'il y a un trou en F4 plus en Détroit
donc il y va
et la question c'est ce que les blancs
sont à temps pour jouer un dessin qui se
venger sur le pion E5 mais j'ai tendance
à dire non parce qu'il y a des deux
emprise
complexe en tout cas
5 d'ailleurs
[Musique]
pour les
pour les Noirs d'ailleurs B5 ouais
cavaliers 5 peut-être plus logique pour
toucher le
[Musique]
et on défend le sein comme ça
et si tu veux un capteur
mais de rien j'ai un très bon accent
merci je sais si tu veux un capteur ring
je crois que pendant le tournoi il y a
une remise de 100 dollars sur le
matériel
d'accord je vais en parler à ma
comptable
d'ailleurs d'abord
mais ça peut ça se peut que tu en
prennes quand même pour la chambre de la
fille ça peut être de ta fille ça peut
ça peut te mettre très très bien Mathieu
c'est vrai pour savoir si tu as acheté
une bonne qualité d'air ouais là t'es
pas bien tout d'un coup en fait tu viens
en commentaire le tournoi tu viens de
perdre 300 balles ça c'est terrible ce
serait beau que tu sois payé en capteur
d'air
mais honnêtement c'est pas bête bah oui
non mais je sais
tu serais tout ouais c'est beau en fait
une ouverture pas folichonne est-ce que
tu veux que ça t'intéresse si je regarde
les autres parties c'est des trucs
intéressants ou tu t'en fous complet
alors Karl Seine peut-être enfin regarde
que la première division
non mais bien sûr Carlson s'intéressant
la pause
Parana mais Sarana qui lui a collé au
championnat du monde
j'étais juste un petit taille parce que
c'est vrai que la partie de la liésa
c'est pas
pas fou
c'est rigolo on va pas forcément rester
dessus pour le moment mais c'est pour
faire un petit tour il a pas ok en
faisant une catalane et la limite il a
du Grand rock
qui arrive il y a que j'ai 5 qui touche
à 7
tu fais la chute après ce que limite
envie de bon déjà tu peux reprendre un 4
mais tu peux aussi cacher
en tout cas il est pas mal
je t'avoue je vous avoue que je suis un
petit peu agacé de pas avoir la caméra
de fil rouge à sa m'agace en fait c'est
des trucs qui m'agace
mais ça vient de lui tu penses
probablement c'est sûr ouais mais je
trouve ça assez agaçant en fait
enfin ça m'énerve en fait j'arrive les
Français on est toujours pour le joueur
français il y a pas de souci mais bon
parfois
il y a que moi que ça énerve ce genre de
choses ou ça énerve aussi dans le chat
un petit peu
je veux faire
il a envoyé du lourd d'accord
très agressif mais ça peut se retourner
contre lui ok ouais la partie en plus il
se passe rien
j'ai trois c'est logique en fait il veut
contrôler donc la Casa F4 le défaut
c'est que ça fait des petits trous
mais la question c'est ce qu'on peut en
profiter
[Musique]
pour l'instant je vois pas comment
d'ailleurs
tu peux nous dire ce qui se passe du
côté de Naka
par curiosité
j'ai regardé en fait il envoie tout dans
la gueule Google mais ça peut se
retourner genre il a fait un pion il a
fait un H4 H500 OK
on a beaucoup de mal à réagir avec vous
le chat parce que ça en fait on a une
minute 30 en toute décalage parce qu'on
est en plus on stream et sur Youtube et
sur twitch ce qui fait que ça nous
rajoute encore 30 secondes de délai donc
quand vous posez une question dites vous
qu'on la reçoit une minute 15 minutes 30
après donc on peut pas si vous avez une
question sur un coup que vous voulez
rebondir sur une variante dont on parle
on pourra absolument pas vous répondre
je préfère le dire
ça c'est quand même un truc à améliorer
pour le futur donc
que le délai c'est bien pour la triche
mais après j'arrive pas trop à
comprendre honnêtement je leur fais
assez confiance sur la triche ils font
le maximum mais je vois pas l'intérêt de
décaler les coûts sur twitch pour la
triche parce que de toute façon si tu
veux vraiment tricher c'est pas ça qui
va t'arrêter
mais après ça ouais peut-être qu'il
pense limiter un tout petit peu ouais
mais tu en as la commande là dans le
chat pour pour le chasseur mais qu'on
n'arrive pas à choper au bon moment tu
vois la remise de 100 dollars
dans les annonces ça fait plaisir les
tarifs il faudra aller voir après
Mathieu Mathieu qui va aller faire du
shopping
c'est une cadence qui est un peu bizarre
non au début c'est assez mou il joue
comme un 20 minutes tu as l'impression
et ça va accélérer
un coup il y a toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier il y a plus que 6 minutes
qu'on suit donc ça peut accélérer très
vite
l'attaque est passée il va me mettre la
pression avec le nom
Magnus je pense
et ouais
Wesley
joue contre qui parce qu'en fait c'est
une caméra que j'ai pas et je sais pas
pourquoi
je l'ai pas moi
la position est très solide enfin très
symétrique je veux dire solide
ok peut-être égal j'en sais rien
Ludwig qui est très heureux du ring
ça peut lui être très utile
je pense qu'il pensait à autre chose
Mathieu c'est le hub qui l'a un peu
vous m'avez perdu
oh mais c'est trop c'est beaucoup trop
en fait
je vais aller voir qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces trucs il y a pas non ça marche
pas j'allais dire
le roi il peut peut-être avoir même des
cavaliers géants maintenant
qui peuvent arriver
il faut mettre des piles dans ce truc
c'est pas bien
mais prends-en un sans pile
il y en a qui se branche il y en a qui
se branche
tu peux tu peux faire les deux il y en a
qui se branche directement
donc
je pense il va commencer un peu mieux
ça fait très chipo non
déjà qu'il y avait sans doute
j'ai 4 et quelque chose comme dame 3
ou 3D
je ferai de Me deux sans trop réfléchir
il a fait la
sans trop réfléchir
non parce qu'en fait il faut comprendre
un truc c'est que Dame des trois ça
égalise pas vraiment je pense
[Musique]
ça gagne pas un pion déjà
je peux pas parce que je peux pas faire
quel point qu'il y a toujours dedans
donc tu as raison faut bouger le
cavalier d'abord donc est-ce que tu le
mets en C4 ou de toute façon il a fait
fouger 4
mais oui c'était sûrement il a pensé
qu'il était moins bien
alors des fois tu peux jouer des dames
prends des deux pour rigoler
moi ça donnerait la paire de fou pour
pas grand chose
[Musique]
presse au blanc de jouets
et ces quatre qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
pour protéger le pion
bon je l'attaque pas vraiment c'est un
peu le défaut
faire gaffe quand même de pas se prendre
un faux point F3 échec dans le mauvais
tempo d'ailleurs est-ce que
tu fais B5 je prends un cavalier E3
ok il a fait cavalier C4 parce qu'en
fait B5 au début je me suis dit qui tu
pouvais pas prendre le 5
parce que tu prends le 2 qui prend des 7
x 3 échec il faut être échec mais en
fait tu peux faire quel prix je pense
et tu touches le ok au 3 directs alors
tu touches le fou
tu touches B5 il a pas le temps je pense
de prendre quatre parce que hyper une
pièce qui prend G4 ça me prend à 4 et ça
c'est un truc ça va ça peut vite vite
tourner de fois cinq seuls coups
[Musique]
ah oui du coup comme j'ai mis le chat en
grand je vois que maintenant je vois
l'évaluation OK
mais bon je pense pas qu'il fasse B5 il
a fait fouder 6
ok pour moi il est un peu mieux
peut-être comment tu fais cavalier 3
après tu peux lui dire genre fou ces
deux avec l'idée qui a eu lieu trois et
quand il fait fout aussi ce qui est G5
ouais c'est pas bête ça
peut-être que sans doute
parce que maintenant que trois fois
aussi et là cavalier H4
ok non mais il est mieux là tu sais pas
quoi faire dans les trucs comme ça
tu as regardé la Bundes ce weekend j'ai
pensé à toi non j'ai eu du mal en fait à
trouver comment la regarder j'ai sué
j'ai regardé la partie de parram ça m'a
fait rire parce que position il faut
tourner il fait la fin n'importe quoi il
fait aussi plus ça et puis après il a
fait une erreur il doit jouer actif sur
le roi adverse il fait nulle facile
qu'on te rapporte
et quand il a l'activité il est quand
même vraiment impressionnant il joue
bien
il a gagné des points
je l'ai pas eu mais moi j'aurais des
regrets parce qu'en fait la deuxième et
il gagne une partie il gagne la première
avec les Blancs contre un pas très fort
enfin pas mauvais mais et la deuxième en
fait il a un 26 Colars toi qui est
dangereux et il y a tout ce qui rate
complètement son ouverture avec les
Blancs et il fait nul en deux heures et
la dernière partie mais je veux un mec
Santos là il joue pas sans touche la
torche donc la partie inintéressante
en fait son idée c'était tout rachant
j'arrive pas à comprendre son idée
accroche de deux ok donc B5 donc
cavalier 3 normalement ABK E3 ça moi
j'aime bien moi j'ai deux en fait
il est mieux rangé de le roi
ça me paraît pas une priorité mais bon
pourquoi pas ok le 3 qu'est-ce qu'il
veut faire foi
va mettre le rangée qui prend un 4
est-ce qu'on a une tactique c'est ça
qu'il faut se poser fouder
qui avait les pro E4 5 peut-être
[Musique]
c'est la partie
ça va être la partie il a fait ABAB il
va faire cavalier 3
[Musique]
lf6 et prendre en B5 prise des 5 et
prends des 5
on va avoir un 4 20 c'est là que ça va
s'aimer
il y a ici doit pas être bien de pas
avoir la caméra de fil rouge à moi ça me
rendrait fou à sa place je te le dis
tout de suite
ouais ils sont pas il y a beaucoup de
parents dans le haut niveau mais pas
tous donc
non mais moi c'est pas le côté parano
c'est le côté c'est les règles
tu es pas là je joue pas en fait
par principe Magus le défonce
une accueil va gagner en ligne je pense
la finale il a un plan de plus là tu as
fait bout dans l'ouverture il a pas
paniqué
[Musique]
doit pas marcher à cause de fous prends
F3 échec dame G4 dames
[Musique]
je montre ta variante armathieu elle
avait l'air correct
ouais
sachant qu'il se les fait coller la
dernière fois
oui mais ça j'adore ce joueur parce
qu'il a plein d'idées dans les
ouvertures j'aime les gens qui
travaillent et qui cherchent des idées
même si l'ordi aime pas en fait il joue
des petites
tu dois bien jouer appeler aimer un
joueur qui s'appelle rachmanoff
re et en fait ils sont jamais des idées
quand même
bien parce que je l'ai défoncé une fois
en partie non du coup j'aime bien le mec
mais non je sais pas il a écrit un livre
sur ses merdes ça ne me donnait pas trop
envie de le lire
ces anglaises ils jouent sur la 6ème
cavalier
c'est incroyable il m'a dit pour
quelqu'un comme comme moi qui ai pas le
temps pour les ouvertures ou quoi il me
dit rachmanoff c'est pas mal
si tu as pas beaucoup de temps il a des
idées qui sont pas faciles à réfuter et
t'as pas trop de théories à connaître au
final en fait après c'est des plans
alors moi je l'avais je l'avais eu dans
l'ouverture quand même avec les noirs
et j'ai réussi à mettre le bordel avec
les noirs et il est rentré dans une
tactique il a serré fil du matériel ça
marchait pas tu n'as que je me sens pas
qu'une tour de plus
une qualité il y a un peu de jeu déjà
c'est une bonne nouvelle quand elle est
noire et de plus mais finalement je
crois que j'ai eu une tour
en partie un petit peu difficile de
trouver pour nous le rythme en début de
tournoi on n'a pas une super partie à
des problèmes techniques chez nos
joueurs c'est un peu
parce qu'il veut sur H6
on perd un pion mais on a éliminé le
footcas blanche ouais
donc sur H6
qui avait les trois
ouais c'était un peu particulier
non il veut il veut je crois
je voulais un peu de cavalier géant
[Musique]
mais mais mais pour le coup c'est mieux
jouer avec cavalier G5 parce que tu
élèves à faire f3g 4 peut-être si ça
passe même si oui c'est un joli coup
pour quand tu fais 3 ou H3 je te fous
des 7 très joli coup je pense ça fait
f3g4
et repartir avec le cheval
c'est moche non c'est très moche
[Rires]
désolé
ok
G6 c'est terrible en fait
il faudrait que ton cahier soit déjà en
G3 peut-être
il est en train de tank du temps la
partie est très bizarre en soi en fait
ils ont pas compris
je joue avec son téléphone
ah il a peut-être un problème avec avec
du matériel informatique ou quelque
chose dans de ce style là ouais ouais
c'est pas possible en fait
c'est pas possible ouais il y a une déco
non nous on n'est pas déco où il y a une
déco de chez com non F4
la base je pense que c'est vraiment son
frère ou son père
qui joue
en fait
mais là c'est complètement Matteo
j'attaque F4
de toute façon
mais oui il y a un problème il joue même
pas j'ai ftempo avec aussi peu de temps
c'est bizarre
ouais étonnant
parti extrême
j'ai l'impression
on sait pas trop ce qui s'est passé les
amis et j'ai 4 dans F4 qui est
c'est joli ça
merci
ça c'est joli Mathieu
ok tu peux bouger la dame mais la partie
est vraiment bizarre
elle est dégueulasse
j'ai envie de dire de part et d'autre
allez bizarre cette partie les noirs
de foot qui joue sur un faux rythme mais
même là en fait je trouve qu'il y a
encore faux rythme côté Riga ici parce
qu'il va retendre 45 secondes là-dessus
tu es pas obligé quand même
ok joli on apprend 4 cavaliers de maths
[Musique]
donc prise prise
il y a pas de gain direct non
je vais le montrer parce que c'est joli
toujours cette idée et il y a eu abandon
ouais ouais c'est ça du coup il y a eu
ces derniers
ouais ben écoutez les amis des fêtes
dans les resa dans une partie j'ai envie
de dire un peu
bizarrement et tout d'un coup il se fait
défoncer en trois coups
alors malheureusement je ne vois pas
n'a qu'à connecter même si j'ai
l'impression qu'il joue pour moi il est
pas connecté ça doit être un bug on va
aller voir on va se laisser sauts voir
la fin de la partie je n'aurais pas le
temps de récupérer sa caméra donc je
vais pas la mettre on va laisser
Magnus à gagner
soso ouais c'est assez intéressant en
fait mais là du coup le problème c'est
que j'ai les mauvais noms en fait les
noms ne changent pas avec nos noms comme
ça c'est galère
on va se mettre comme ça demain tu as pu
ma caméra
mais c'est pour avoir les noms quand
même en priorité tant il y en a un qui
me refait le coup de Mathieu Bellamy
dans le chat c'est incroyable
mais ouais je suis vraiment étonné de la
partie
de merde
bah ouais je trouve qu'il a extrêmement
mal joué enfin tu vois j'aurais joué
comme ça j'aurais été dégoûté de moi en
fait
mais à mon avis
je me suis fait une entorse une heure
avant la partie c'est hyper dur de
rester contre peut-être qu'il a une
merde j'aurais un problème informatique
et juste après tu dois jouer tu as pas
dedans peut-être
non on me l'a dit on me l'a dit souvent
ce truc de Sosie fin de Sosie non que je
ressemble mais je trouve pas du tout ça
est-ce qu'il a gagne celle-là il est
normalement non
au prochain
tour F5 tours F3
et ça c'est bien joué
ouais bizarre ce qui fait mais après ça
le droit tellement actif
et si tu commences par G3
parce que G7 bah ton G7 et G2 était
bloqué c'est gagné ça gagne pour Raouf
ah
ça fait nul maintenant je crois l'ordi
données gagnant mais oui parce que sur
approche 5 en fait le roi était bloqué
colonnage ça a gagné
OK
mais ça ça va faire nul il y en a qui
bien mieux la scène où on voit pas les
joueurs je crois qu'elle est mieux celle
où on voit pas les joueurs ouais je suis
assez d'accord
au final c'est je pense c'est mieux de
pas mettre les cames
genre réellement en fait ça apporte pas
grand chose
ah moi j'aime bien ouais
donc
ouais non c'est vrai un sur deux c'est
con
est-ce que Firo est-il lumineux non non
c'est en quatre parties et même quand tu
perds le match c'était pas éliminé il y
a un losaboa
je sais pas du tout comment ça marche
moi ah tu m'as expliqué tout à l'heure
j'ai rien compris mais
donc après
c'est ça
divisions en fait là je regrets j'ose
même en fait si lui c'est juste
j'ai pas vraiment regardé tous les tous
les détails les 2e et 3e division un qui
joue même dans les diffusion inférieur
il doit jouer le 3e division il doit pas
être bien
et ça c'est un truc que j'ai jonant ça
doit être un système de Londres sur ma
partie qu'on est jolie je pense ok des
deux tu laisses prendre des deux oui
c'est connu ça c'est plutôt pas mal non
non ça va complètement j'ai 6 c'est le
nouvel antidote
arrête c'est un truc qui était bien il y
a les joueurs 2017 je pense
c'est pas très connu toi mais c'était il
y a cinq six ans
il faut mettre un peu l'air des joueurs
c'est vrai que c'est important
parce que tu as récupéré d'autres r non
mais on peut quand même refaire un petit
tour sur l'air d'Aniche
qui reste quand même assez correct
non franchement pas terrible mais il a
deux enfants en plus
mais moi ce que je me dis c'est
peut-être que fearuja en fait il a un
air de merde il arrive pas à jouer
c'est peut-être pour ça
tout s'explique
Sacha 3e division attends il doit se
tuer Sacha
division 3 il doit être su quand même
est-ce que ça un énorme bordel ce tourne
ah je vais pas vous mentir moi j'ai rien
compris et en fait les divisions tu
montes tu montes l'année prochaine non
non c'est chaque tournoi en fait c'est
chaque tournoi tu es dans une division
c'est le c'est le tournoi du vendredi
qui décide de ta division en fait
alors chaque nouveau tournoi il y aura
un tournoi vendredi qualif
et Étienne il a pas joué ce qu'on était
au chaos boxing avec Sardoche et puis en
plus il a hésité à le faire après il m'a
dit
hop si je viens maintenant sur Internet
j'aime bien c'est parti ouais après je
suis pas sûr qu'il joue le prochain non
plus ça le je sais pas ça dépendra c'est
vraiment s'il a rien à faire et qu'il a
envie de s'entraîner d'après ce que j'ai
compris oui oui non mais c'est un bon
entraînement mais ouais d'ailleurs le
combat moi j'ai bien aimé j'ai suivi et
j'avais des potes qui étaient sur place
on s'écrivait des textos j'ai bien aimé
le tournoi
j'ai vu que les deux premiers combats
mais j'ai trouvé ça sympa regardez pour
une fois parce que d'habitude j'avais
regardé d'autres combats j'avais pas
trop aimé c'était peut-être bien
commenté bien commenté et non mais je
trouve que les combats étaient assez
marrants et équilibré il y a eu du fight
beau fighting faites des 1500 qui joue
entre eux mais ils sont en mettre plein
la gueule à la box comme aux échecs donc
je trouvais ça bien
après c'est peut-être pas si simple mais
mais quand même c'est une Toto
passer une qualité plutôt mais
attends
il a pas l'air bien mais l'ordi donne
fouf 5 ah oui on n'a pas vu on est con
et oui
en fait ça doit être égal la petite
avantage blanc mais c'est même pas sûr
n'importe quoi qu'est-ce que tu en sais
que c'est n'importe quoi
j'imagine que c'est quand même leur
métier ils ont fait un truc avec des
quand ils disent que c'est pas bien que
c'est bien
j'imagine que ça a du sens j'espère pour
eux
est-ce que ça recommence comment quand
dès que c'est fini je crois que c'est à
10 minutes après la fin des parties ça
reprend j'ai vu un mec écrit qui a écrit
ça mais alors est-ce que c'est que pour
la pour les autres divisions est-ce que
c'est pour la première division j'en
sais rien en fait il y a beaucoup de
trucs qui se jouent en même temps
qui est en prise mais à la fin il va
être
et d'ailleurs je ne connais pas son
adversaire
ça marche non je pense
sinon il y a
[Musique]
je vois pas de coup
dans les pas obligé de prendre aux
échecs on peut jouer genre des coins
intermédiaires genre cavalier 4 tu vas
être obligé d'aller en dessin tu peux
lancer vite
je vois pourquoi il réfléchit
je gagne
exact
je le connais pas
qui c'est en fait
non non
pour résumer à l'histoire d'air en fait
c'est pas une connerie c'est juste c'est
un sponsor du tournoi qui fait qui
propose des choses intéressantes il y
aura un lien vous pourrez voir si ça
vous intéresse c'est les sponsors du
temps
c'est quoi c'est youngui OK contre ça
doit ni ça c'est division 2 aussi ouais
en fait division 1 il y a tout qui est
terminé déjà
est-ce que tu peux pas trouver Google
comme ça son adversaire c'est quoi son
pseudo
comment je peux savoir
je crois que je le trouve pas non plus
j'ai un bug un peu bizarre et
j'ai ni l'un ni l'autre en fait
Thomas
c'est particulier je les ai ni l'un ni
l'autre
il va monter en plus là pour l'instant
tout n'est pas clair ah ça y est on a
enfin la cam d'Ali resa
c'est un peu moi j'aime pas quand les
choses sont marchent pas correctement en
fait ça me il y avait ni Raouf nially
resa donc moi en fait je comprends pas
pourquoi ils ont le droit de jouer en
fait ça me c'est des choses qui me qui
me plaisent pas vraiment en fait je peux
pas l'expliquer enfin si je peux
l'expliquer en fait quand il y a des
trucs qui suivent pas les règles du jeu
ça m'énerve en fait
c'est comme ça en fait que ce soit les
raisins ou pas bon juste il prend
forfait et puis c'est pas grave on
avance et on passe à autre chose mais je
trouve ça un peu étonnant en fait il y a
déjà tellement de problèmes de triche
que ça m'agace un peu qu'on laisse les
gens faire ce qu'ils veulent en fait il
faut vraiment être très strict avec ça
mais du coup sur la caméra d'habitude tu
me sers vachement là on voit on voit mon
canapé
je vais pouvoir récupérer les caméras
donc Erika ici tu vois il est en haut
maintenant donc on va le passer en
on peut laisser en haut en fait en vrai
quoi
donc on va le mettre comme ça
moi ce qui me fait peur chez lui c'est
j'ai l'impression qu'il s'emmerde
je fais un truc technique Mathieu
et du coup je vais récupérer ça
maintenant
dégarni à 25 ans
les victimes d'alopécie il est pas bien
il est pas bien
les jouets plusieurs fois sur deux fois
en longueur
qui mange
mais il doit pas être bien parce qu'il a
perdu la première au blanc quand même à
lire les raisins après
préoccuper plus que ça après Righi gros
joueur quand même très bon rapides très
bon sur Internet
ah c'est un joueur de rapide ça se voit
très clairement il a un peu léger pour
l'instant pour l'instant en longue
et ben voilà on commence à avoir quelque
chose d'un peu sérieux
il mange des cavites
il a pas l'air d'être en grande forme
non
[Musique]
il faut découper à gauche non et dès
qu'elle est
tu m'as compris
donc ça commence pas c'est un peu
dommage après peut-être qu'il recommence
aux heures précises sur la Division 1
c'est à dire
on est bien
donc D4 cavaliers
C3 quand les gens font des 5 tu te
rappelles on avait vu des parties de
irrigues ici et du coup alors ça c'est
mon répertoire de ce que je joue en
blitz sur Swisscom avec le Nord je me
manquais en dessert je fais G6 et je
joue pour 5
il a bien raison
tu fais quoi tu bois de l'eau tu bois du
thé pendant tes parties
tu vois quoi toi
moi je bois de l'eau mais hier un moment
je j'avais envie d'un boost je me suis
fait un oasis tropical un demi verre
c'est le meilleur
c'est vraiment pas bon mais tropical
c'est très très bon
en fait j'ai une époque d'ailleurs
l'année où j'étais sponsor j'ai mangé
pas le midi
mais je mangeais pendant les parties OK
et c'est
du chocolat noir c'est pas censé être
pire que rien de faire ça mais je
faisais un bon petit déj un peu tard
enfin à 9h30 10h
bien marché pour moi après j'aime bien
manger donc c'est un peu con à perdre un
repas mais en plus moi c'était aussi
pour un truc pratique c'est que
je me prépare beaucoup trop
du coup ça me fait gagner c'est le temps
de ta vie enfin le temps de sortir aller
manger revenir
j'ai économise 45 minutes de prépa mais
ça te dérangeait pas de jouer le ventre
vite même si tu manges sur place le
temps que l'énergie monte au cerveau etc
c'est un gros petit déj et des fois je
me prenais genre un fruit ou je me
faisais un petit sandwich du petit déj
c'est pas une bêtise je faisais vraiment
la partie pendant la partie je mangeais
et je vais bien
j'ai jamais vu qui que ce soit faire ça
c'est la première fois que j'entends
quelqu'un conseiller ça
pourtant des conseils de Vlad j'en ai eu
j'en ai entendu des bizarres dis ça
parlait pas de nourriture
c'est franchement un jour goutte c'est
le seul qui est bon il est vraiment
et hier je me suis fait mon petit
gobelet là je suis content j'ai gagné
facile
mais tu le bois quand tu es gagnant déjà
ce truc là
ouais
complètement avec ton oasis tropical
c'est pas possible en fait des fois ça
m'arrive quand j'ai soif aussi
d'autant plus en fait
tu dois l'apprécier à 200 % ton oasis
je préfère courge
je crois qu'elle ira il est sur les
pistaches à fond là il a l'air motivé
il peut le faire à un point c'est rien
il est juste mené un zéro ça c'est
intéressant je sais pas moi j'aurais
plutôt envie de jouer 4 mais en fait
quand je joue au 4 ça réactive le foie
H2 généralement il faut faire un petit
undy contre le foie j'ai un petit muret
un petit indice c'est quoi cette
expression
S
il y en a plein qui disent tropical
c'est le meilleur et canette c'est
meilleur c'est vrai c'est vrai aussi
c'est souvent meilleur canette ce truc
là que bouteille je sais pas pourquoi
est-ce que les blancs peuvent mettre un
caillou B5
je commence à préférer les Noirs perso
le cavalier en dessin que je trouve
hyper fort
moi je suis en fait c'est quoi ton plan
tu joues pourquoi F5 F4 c'est 5 je
trouve pas non pour moi tu joues pour
aucun des deux
et après
et après je clique un peu une dame en
dessert je te clique peut-être une tour
en E7 une tour en 8
et moi j'ai remarqué un truc j'aime pas
forcément jouer avec une position où
j'ai pas de rupture
voilà je clique juste en fait là je joue
pour cliquer
bah je joue pour le clic
mais moi j'aime bien jouer les positions
j'ai quelques coups logiques à cliquer
en fait
ouais
4 5 prochains coups mais juste est-ce
qu'à la fin des 4 5 prochaines couteau
tu auras une idée c'est pas sûr en fait
je te rassure en long que j'aimais bien
aussi j'adorais pouvoir cliquer quelques
coups
mais j'ai remarqué je joue plus vite
qu'avant
c'est l'âge ça
t'as plus le temps non non
je suis plus stressé je me dis si je
suis mal au temps je suis complètement
nul maintenant
[Rires]
je suis complètement gagnant et je
voulais pas descendre sous les 20
minutes j'ai fini avec 30 minutes faut
prendre alors ça j'aurais même pas
envisagé le coup
moi je t'ai dit tu as noté que j'ai
quand même dit la manœuvre qui a 3 qui
est bessen pour ça que j'ai pas pensé
direct c'est drôle ouais mais tu donnes
plutôt là tu gardes le fou normalement
quand même bien sûr mon ami
je pense je ferai dame bu
D8 qui est prend un huit dame prend E8
18 j'ai pas vraiment de réponse c'est
plus forte en tout cas
si tu savelle nombre de fois que j'ai
pris ça dans ma vie
c'est terrible mais ça c'est pas mieux
au noir attends j'aurais l'impression
d'être à deux doigts d'être gagnant
bouge 7
il va jouer Dame des deux pions pour la
cale tu es mieux matériellement au blanc
mais au loin je suis à fouber 5 de mec
non mais par contre elle peut gagner ça
c'est fort en fait
bon peut-être tourner 8 alors comment ça
s'appelle le truc où manger quand on
était gamin de
[Musique]
et tu craches là tu trouves partout en
Espagne
et la boule
tu vois pas les petites
souvent des petits trucs mais après tu
craches parce que tu prends que la
petite graine comme au milieu ah mais ça
c'est des graines de tournesol mais
c'est moi j'appelle ça des petits pains
quand je t'ai plus des graines de
tournesol j'en ai mangé plein
de tournesol entier que t'ouvre et que
tu vois ouais
en Russie en Ukraine et tout il mange
beaucoup ça aussi ouais et les Espagnols
ils aiment bien
il y en avait partout c'est bon
pour vérifier la qualité de ton air
est-ce que est-ce qu'il a branché son
truc à Rio
vas-y je vais te dire
non le truc d'air je pense qu'on l'aura
pas
par contre on a 8 écritures différentes
je suis d'accord avec du sel
sur ce qu'ils écrivent n'oublie pas
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit on va voir
dans une minute si
happy BIRT veut dire graines de tourne
en français c'est les graines de
tournesol ouais
pour éviter le 4 moi je pense qu'il peut
la gagner égaliser à Lisa
mais là les deux que je joue pour le
gars
s
de courges c'est plus gros c'est sympa
aussi quand je prends un Pokémon
et après et après cavalier B4 ok ce
qu'on bloque
est-ce que les Blancs
moi j'aurais tendance à dire oui
[Musique]
je vous rappelle enfin d'avance plutôt
mais il y aura quatre ans de prises
de manière très directe
la cadence du 15 + 3
à peu près
pour essayer de gagner un temps quoi
mais bon sur H6
un peu le coup
dans lequel j'avais pas du tout fout des
trois dame 16 et comme ça
c'est un peu mieux d'ailleurs tu pourras
aller en F4 aussi avec le cavalier
peut-être
je pense à ça aussi ouais
ok c'est intéressant à ce qui est bien
c'est que pour une partie où il doit
gagner il a une pause qui joue moi il me
fait un peu peur mais
du coup tu as oublié de mettre l'air non
non j'ai mis un petit coup mais j'ai pas
vu l'heure d'aller resa du coup je suis
revenu
mais bon on en a parlé c'est le plus
important
communication commerciale toujours
importante
c'est un
cas particulier
ce serait beau que tu perdes si ton aire
devient trop pourri en fait vu son Sless
plus jouer c'est un peu comme au chasse
boxing on t'arrête en fait tu as
l'arbitre qui vient qui dit oui bon tu
peux plus respirer dégage en fait
ça t'a pas mis bien
là je lis commentaire ouais c'est chiant
et décalage mais on peut pas faire
grand-chose
de décalage c'est difficile de réagir et
de et discuter mais une minute trente tu
peux pas en fait c'est trop on se
rappelle même plus vraiment parfois sur
quoi ça rebondit et puis si on veut
rebondir on peut plus quoi
on peut mais du coup ça ne coupe dans ce
qu'on était en train de dire
complètement ça nous ferme
est-ce que tu veux que j'aille voir les
autres partis un truc intéressant voilà
après là celle-là elle est cool hein
façon Magnus il va fermer c'est sûr
il va fermer
il est moins bien
il devrait il devrait le fermer quand
même je pense
ouais là ouais ça va faire un nul
ouais ça va faire nul mais d'oeuf a fait
un petit piège mais c'est pas passé et
ils ont pas le même métier il y en a un
qui est streamer
il le défonce en faisant n'importe quoi
ah c'est une bonne nouvelle
alors moi perso je m'en fous
mais dans l'absolu ouais j'aime bien la
cage j'aime bien le joueur
très beau joueur
C8 d'ailleurs mais par contre on peut
pas faire le même décalage entre le chat
et le live
tu peux pas
quand j'ai commenté le tata style on
avait 15 minutes de retard et après mais
c'est enfin faudrait le faire à l'envers
là tu peux la vu comment c'est fait tu
peux pas
il faudrait qu'il fasse le truc
différemment en fait
faudra leur dire
je crois que c'est parti pour être comme
ça Mathieu il a fait tour C8 en tout cas
donc il laisse faire le 4 je comprends
rien à ce qu'il fait ça me ferait peur
il y a un cassé 5 encore c'est vrai
dame c'est Camille perlogique
mais dame fou des trois dameset c'est
plus le malin
une fois que tu l'as vu si tu joues tu
aurais pu trouver enfin c'était pas dans
le domaine de l'irréalisable
tu touches le fou tu es une un temps
donc il fait 4 ouais bah il va plutôt
partir en BK j'imagine c'était quand
même l'idée de base de A5
et toi son A5 c'est quand même un vrai
coup pourri il a laissé
des 5 directs
il part sur F4 alors c'est moi je
préfère qu'il aille en F4 même si c'est
moins bon parce que tu as plus de chance
de magouiller avec un cavalier F4 en
réalité il fait une grosse partie de
merde
même après il a pas été hyper précis
j'ai perdu la caméra pourquoi j'ai pas
donc il a fait cavalier F4 il va taper
un peu bah il a 3000 c'est le plus
positif
il a l'air en détente absolu à les
raisins ouais il a il a pas l'air d'être
très concerné par le truc il a pas l'air
d'être
mais bon maintenant qui s'est qualifié
c'est dommage il y a quand même beaucoup
d'argent en jeu on le répète on est
quand même 2 millions en tout de prix
pas toujours facile en de se concentrer
dans ces tournois
ou du moins de rentrer dans le tournoi
aussi il a l'air de regarder c'est vers
le bas comme s'il disait des notifs sur
son téléphone
mais il a l'air vraiment full chill
mais c'est pas toujours facile de c'est
beaucoup plus facile de se connecter de
se concentrer sur internet en blitz
quand rapides cette cadence là elle est
vraiment dur à jouer 15 +
310 + 2 cette année
on sait pas mais on sait que démanté
mais il faut nous prévenir un peu avant
parce que je
comme ça pour savoir en fait c'est à
l'amazone
parce que du coup tu dois t'occuper de
la petite non mais moi je suis content
car au jour faut la remotiver des temps
tu gagnes des miles tu connais pas
l'histoire de quand il s'occupe des
enfants pendant une semaine et je gagne
des mals pour pouvoir faire des soirées
après
tu marques des points bonus avec ta
femme en étant gentil en faisant des
trucs du coup après tu peux faire un
truc toi qu'est-ce que c'est
ah tu mets pas bien avec les miles de
bonus là oh tu me fais chier
non mais je pense les gens vont
comprendre
pas ta femme tu gagnes des masses
et du coup tu gardes les enfants du coup
tu marques des miles et du coup avec les
mêmes tu peux acheter un bon pour faire
quelque chose du coup tu as un bon sorti
et du coup il a toujours dit ça
marche bien et un mot et si imaginons il
fait deux soirées dans la semaine tu lui
proposes un truc le week-end il va dire
désolé j'ai plus de Miles
c'est complexe Mathieu
faut se concentrer sur la sur la partie
Mathieu partie qui est passionnante
vraiment
la partie mais juste c'est en fait pour
moi c'est soit trop long soit trop
rapide en fait ça joue trop mal pour et
c'est trop long
donc ça me va pas c'est un peu long mais
ton français c'est peut-être pas mal
joué sur dame prend dame D8 puis on
prend G5 puis on prend G5 et G5 dame G5
fou D7 il y a des objets de maths à la
fin
important quand même
j'ai pas compris
ah ok ok donc dame prends tu fais
un point de fidélité c'est pas pour moi
les points
ça a l'air fort
j'aime bien il est peut-être bien en
fait
il est peut-être très très bien à les
raisins allez on rentre enfin petit à
petit dans ce tournoi
peut-être c'était le temps d'aérer
l'appartement s'il est sur Paris il doit
pas être super bien avec les particules
fines
parce que c'est pas l'ancien c'est un
nouvel appart non quand il jouait quand
même
il a raison les ongles
ah mais il bouffe quand même
il fait que bouffer en fait bon il a
raison
ici voilà ça c'est du papier à la fin
as-tu bouffes des quatre ça marche comme
ça je pense c'est ça ça
si tu vois si tu vois cette position de
loin tu rentres dedans c'est sûr
parce que c'est pas de bol que ce soit
nul en fait et que tu sois pas gagnant
ouais
cavaliers H3 il veut 4 c'est comme
un folka
faut prendre des fautes
en fait il y a plein de trucs
F5 tu fais faux F8 il a joué à G hi il
menace 4 il menace cavalière 4 c'est
hyper bien joué
F4 il faut pas oublier qu'il y a encore
cavalier F4 puis on prend mesdames G4
tours en fait donc c'est très bien joué
extrêmement bien joué là de la part
d'Ali raza qui est peut-être en train de
faire la différé la pendule 2 minutes 30
d'avance et là regarde pour la première
fois il réfléchit
il a l'air concentré il a enfin une
commission qui lui plaît il a enfin en
train de s'amuser à lireza le prince
un taureau 3 pour protéger le cavalier
pareil logique ou de me trompe trois
mois
je commence à avoir des trucs
pas sûr que ça marche regarde à la fin
c'est pas sûr que ça marche mais t'as
pas envie de le faire
tu es un peu en train de suer Mathieu il
y a même taureau 3 il y a même cavalier
il a fait cavalier
H3 cavalier
ou d'un échec attends mais il est hyper
bien là les raisins tu reprends
tu mets la pression tu as tu es
nettement plus fort enfin tu es pas bien
côté argent argent et Riga ici et est-ce
que tu peux jouer F3 maintenant avec
l'idée contre
à mon avis
genre F3 faut prendre et éperon
F2
il est devant dans le match il doit je
solide un peu avec les Blancs
donc tu vas remanger ok un pion
probablement d'ailleurs il faut que tu
vas peut-être dames 5 faut prendre des
quatre ah mais il faut prendre des sets
d'un projet
dommage de pas avoir F5 ici
je vois pas de solutions
plutôt faible fous de couleur opposé
pour faire gaffe
quand même
qui lui reste encore une position avec
les Blancs il faut pas se suicider ici
quand tu as les raisins
je vais allumer la lumière
un peu de bol je trouve quand même côté
Riga ici là dessus
mais bon il était quand même toujours en
contrôle il y a 10 minutes nous allons
poser une question de la différence
entre GM et GMI j'aime c'est plus court
et le i pour international mais c'est la
même chose c'est devenu la même chose ça
n'a pas toujours été
en anglais ils disent pas
en français on dit Grand Maître je sais
pas pourquoi
mais il trouve pas mais il y a peut-être
pas de
du coup
c'est 5 pour aller dans le 4 et
5 5
il faut être méfiant il y a aussi de
dame D8 d'hommes prendre B6 des fois il
faut faire gaffe le problème c'est quand
on prend B2 on prend un pion qui ne qui
n'est pas passé un qui est bloqué il
fait cavalier aussi sans premier
j'aurais probablement ça défend un petit
peu les cases on imagine un dame un dame
F5 et peut-être dame prend B2 mais il y
aura encore du fou qui pourrait revenir
en C4 et comme le dit Mathieu une
agglomération de pièces là je sur le
casse blanche extrêmement dangereux fou
il absorbé deux c'est pas c'était bien
joué tu en prends un cadre de rendre le
matériel
peut-être faut jouer dames et 5 alors
et si je fais cavalier F6
peut-être j'ai changé du coup
ouais mais du coup tu es moins bien non
ce KFC je voulais jouer
trois tu es obligé de prendre en fait je
vais demander si je peux faire damage 5
cavalier G5 je crois un peu des cases
blanches
et j'ai pas le temps de venir consolider
avec mon foot
je sais pas ça passe peut-être pas mon
truc
là il est en difficulté il peut la
perdre
s'il la paire le match est quasi perdu
après comme je disais hein c'est pas
terminé dame D1 peut-être très malin
parce qu'il veut Damas
2 n'importe quoi non non c'est pas mal
attends ça menace pas maths mais ça peut
forcer aux cavaliers à revenir défendre
les artistes je fais pousser quatre
c'est quoi ton idée j'imagine qu'il veut
dans ma chambre
et là j'ai plus
mais c'est peut-être malin en tout cas
il le fait
ouais c'est pas des raisins c'est quand
même pas très bien joué la partie dans
sa globalité
et en fait je comment tu dois jeter des
8 là
il est clairement moins bien du coup il
y a les cases blanches le roi a pu
faible puis en plus
peut-être dame D1 c'était ouais
c'est une bonne idée mais après cavalier
H2 c'est vrai que
en fait il mobilise ta dame et le
cavalier adverse tu restes à deux
comptes de l'autre côté mais
c'est pas bien joué ouais
ouais il est pas dedans
il est pas dedans
il a joué des coups de merde
pose une vraie question est-ce qu'il
jouerait mieux avec artings
je pense que oui il a pas l'air connecté
c'est peut-être ça qui lui coûte au
final
ah non c'est mort en fait c'est juste
complètement foutu
quelqu'un qui va faire dame 4 mesdames 4
c'est joli mais après faut prendre 6 tu
pleures en fait
et après faut pas oublier que les
finales tu es pas sûr qu'elles tiennent
avec ton pion de moi c'est ça le
problème
je pense qu'il y aurait pour limite il
mériterait de la perdre après maintenant
là on rentre dans du 30 secondes chacun
dès la première journée tu as quasi plus
de suspense sur le tournoi pour nous
quoi
gagner le looser bracket et gagner le
tournoi mais bon c'est quand même un peu
tristoun quoi il aurait pu jouer contre
Magnus au prochain tour ça aurait été
sympa
là
mais c'est quoi le rajout on a dit trois
qui sont hyper nombre non
mais le truc c'est qu'il a plus de coup
et j'ai 4
c'est dommage parce qu'il était bien en
jambe
ouais mon moi il a une position après
c'est pas si simple à gagner peut-être
tactique miroir G2 qui est 3 qui est C4
ça a l'air complètement fini
il en a peut-être trop fait un
ok bon il essaie de défendre mais en
plus ce qui est terrible c'est que les
fous de couleur opposés ça favorise
l'attaque et ils sont fondement il
serait de ce côté-là ce serait beaucoup
moins grave
[Musique]
il va essayer de se barrer avec son roi
de l'autre côté tu veux faire quoi
c'est dur hein c'est très très dur non
c'est 10 secondes contre 15
il peut c'est plutôt une bonne idée
parce que son roi est tellement faible
refuser qui est un
mais ça passe même pas complètement ce
qui peut prendre F7 quand même c'est
dommage parce qu'il avait pas vu ça
le petit coup de butoir
après on sait que la connexion non n'est
pas toujours la meilleure
ça peut se jouer à lako ça c'est bizarre
d'avoir laissé ça ouais
j'avais pas vu
maintenant
mais il a juste gardé il avait roi C7 en
fait il
là il avait roi C7
oui oui
il voulait pas le faire depuis du coup
oui je sais mais là il l'avait enfin il
était pas obligé le seul coup qu'il joue
tempo c'est roi E7 en fait là tu fais
roi il a juste donné une pièce en main
je veux dire
mais depuis tout à l'heure il peut jouer
mais il voulait pas
enfin quand tu es obligé tu es obligé
quoi
bah ouais ouais mais ouais
bon il a super mal joué à Lisa refroidi
il s'est passé quoi dans les autres
parties Mathieu je suis en train d'aller
voir Magnus à la surprise générale va
gagner
complètement gagné ouais en réalité
il était il était mal mais ça peut durer
longtemps
elle dirait ça donc c'est fini il y a
une nul entre ma mère faisceau et à 2
euros aussi ok
sachant encore
je ne peux pas le trouver
en ami c'est pas je peux pas le voir
connecter il y a un bug des fois qui
arrive et il y a des joueurs tu peux
pour une raison X ou Y tu ne peux pas
aller voir connecter
je vais essayer de faire un refresh
c'est étonnant mais c'est un bug qui
arrive
ouais non je l'aurais pas d'un cas
il a une finale pion de plus qu'elle a
l'air de gagner en ligne mais 20
secondes qu'on 4 donc c'est pas encore
sûr
ça a l'air quand même bien gagner
d'ailleurs
OK
donc en réalité le match le plus serré
c'est ma médof contre
c'est ma méthode une partie pas toujours
intéressante à gagner du coup il y a 2-0
2 0 2 0 et 1 et 2 nul c'est rigolo
pourtant c'est un genre tactique mais il
est hyper solide
il est hyper solide ma métaphore
quand il veut pas je prends le gain il a
laissé l'enfer
donc on va les enlever
donc ça reprend air fixe tu penses du
coup
j'imagine que oui d'ailleurs je vais te
mettre il y a une petite pub à mettre
donc on va voir une double pub à Mathieu
ça très bien
[Musique]
on peut les repasser n'importe quel
moment sur votre sur demande
elles sont très très belles mais ouais
les raisins qui a pas branché la qualité
de l'air et qui est peut-être très très
mal à cause de ça
mais c'est bizarre de pas avoir la
qualité de l'air de tout le monde
ouais je suis vraiment étonné Mathieu
par le niveau de jeu d'aller réserve un
petit peu déçu pour te dire la vérité je
m'attendais à mieux
moi je m'étonne à rien mais l'autre jour
continue à rejouer il a bien joué parce
que sinon il jouait plus trop récemment
non
ouais là il m'a paru quand même
nettement en dessous je me suis regardé
la vidéo de son match contre chaos
ça joue bien mais il se fait dominer
quand même il est un peu moins fort
ouais
mais bon c'est le boss
en tout cas en tout cas belle
compétition comme je disais c'est le
circuit il y a le plus d'argent
il n'y a pas vraiment eu de belles
parties non même dans ce que tu as
regardé à côté sur cette première
journée il y a rien de la première de
Magnus c'était quand même sympa il a
joué l'attaque
hyper facile tu as besoin qui joue un
enfant
de la blague non Magnus sa première
était pas mal
il a fait une bonne une bonne frère
parti avec les recopés et tout
donc
en fait il y a plein de divisions et il
y a des joueurs genre grichu qu'on est
vivant 3 ça paraît ouf mais
ça prouve qu'il y a de l'argent
il est pas encore éliminé parce que
c'est en quatre parties par contre il
est un peu dans le dur il y a deux zéro
donc
c'est bon
un commentaire qui me fait rire
il y en a des marrons
ouais ouais c'est il faudra quand même
leur dire que enfin il faut améliorer le
côté pour ceux qui commentent avec un
chat c'est quand c'est un plateau de
télé on s'en fout
il s'en foutent ils disent pas le chat
mais nous
c'est pas très grave
Mathieu qui est pas bien je trouve ça
con moi j'aime bien
tu es très heureux aussi
c'est juste qu'un jour aujourd'hui où on
n'est pas très bien servi par les Game
c'est un peu complexe quoi
il s'est passé quoi ton nom féminin
qui a encore gagné
je suis en train de me poser la même
question
ouh là elle a l'air foutu elle a un pion
de moins elle en a gagné quatre
d'affilés les quatre premières et en
plus tu as vu le style
mais elle envoie elle envoie du steak à
chaque partie elle a joué une slam elle
s'est pris cela des changes
ah mais elle connaissait pas
c'est pas de bol
du coup il était moins bien tout de
suite
pourtant c'est un an de cramique à la
ligne
dans
OK
bon intéressant
on me remercie de signaler quoi que
c'est pas bien
c'est des trucs que je dis une fois de
tiens sur l'erreur de Firo à la première
partie tu vois seulement de décalage non
mais moi tu vois c'est des trucs je dis
une fois deux fois trois fois 10 fois 15
fois 20 fois au bout d'un moment oui bon
merci au revoir tu vois c'est tu me
connais c'est moi c'est les premiers
trucs sur lesquels je réagis et qui me
font tiquer mais après si tout le monde
s'en fout tout le monde s'en fout aussi
tu vois commenter le dernier tournoi
c'était quand même en décalé mais on
pouvait interagir
mais là pas du tout dans là c'est trop
quand c'est 20 30 secondes en décalé tu
peux mais une minute 30 tu peux plus tu
peux plus interagir avec le chat c'est
pas possible
en plus en partie longue à la limite
c'est tellement lent tu peux attendre
mais ouais dans tous les cas tu as pas
une conversation fluide ça c'est
c'est pour la fluidité il faudra
repasser Mathieu
pour la fluidité il faudra repasser
c'est pas très grave hein
sinon ça serait pas drôle je pense que
ça doit reprendre à 19h un
personnellement
quand est-ce comme là il montre du ski
de fond
je suis en train de regarder
championnat du monde de billard reprend
mercredi non
possible comment se maintenir
[Musique]
c'est des belles capsules
ah c'est utile surtout
mais ils sont tellement bons les
Norvégiens
là ils ont un mec en gros il a le droit
une voire deux erreurs au tir de plus
que les autres tellement il est plus
rapide sur le ski
et pourquoi il fait pas du sprint juste
directement
je pense c'est plus tu as plus d'argent
on a bien
OK
et vraiment très très bon en plus il y a
en plus il tire très bien
donc
il est vraiment facile toi
et du coup
[Musique]
il gagne quasiment tout le temps en ce
moment
après si tu es bon au tir enfin si tu es
mais ouais c'était meilleur dans les
deux disciplines c'est un peu c'est un
peu comme si quelque chose c'est du
check boxing il est dans les médias et
en ski je te dire il prend une minute
bah sur le grand tu sais quand ils font
2/3 debout de te recoucher soit dans le
sprint le sprint il peut être battu mais
même pas sûr
moi je sais pas ce qui est du tout j'ai
jamais ce qui est de ma vie
se faire pour que tu connais pas dispo
mais ouais maintenant ça va être plus
dur mais prendre des cours à Victoria
comme ça
j'en ai jamais fait moi qui me blesse
tout le temps je crois faire de me faire
les chevilles
c'est pas possible
je ne sais c'est ça
est-ce que ça va bientôt reprendre
ça devrait
ce qu'ils sont en studio moi aussi du
coup j'ai mis le
plateau principal avec notre plaisir
ouais
un peu et tout
présentatrice et enceinte sévère
d'ailleurs
elle doit pas être bien il y a plus
Martin aux œufs ouais mais avant on est
censé avoir des bons quand même mais
récemment
ils ont des coups de moins bien mais
l'autre jour il y avait une course de
biathlon qui était génial parce qu'en
fait
les conditions étaient catastrophiques
et en fait tu as différentes marques de
ski et genre si tu avais une marque de
ski par rapport à l'autre tu gagnais 2
minutes
c'est trop de différence toi pour une
marque de ski donc il y en avait qui
était vraiment pénalisé c'est un peu la
même difficile avec avec ring si tu l'as
branché ou si tu l'as pas
la différence est quand même importante
Mathieu
ça s'est vu pour pour Ali un sport ultra
mineur ça va c'est comme la pétanque
bon sport la pétanque d'ailleurs j'adore
est-ce que vous avez des conseils pour
un nouveau échec
facile sur YouTube
c'est une bonne chaîne bah oui pour moi
est-ce que tu la regardes du coup si tu
as déjà vu une vidéo
je pense pas enfin si j'ai vu mais j'ai
pas regardé en entier non
bah j'ai regardé déjà quand tu vois le
thème je comprends de quoi tu veux
parler je vois si c'est utile ou pas toi
après si vous voulez regarder une bonne
vidéo ma vidéo sur la partie de la
dernière fois il était bien elle a bien
marché
on a 75000 vues je crois tu peux dire
combien on en a exactement au moins
c'est quasiment encore je pense
je veux dire c'était un c'est un joli
thème qu'on a ouais non mais surtout en
plus
on en a tourné une autre d'ailleurs
partie d'ordi mais elle est un peu moins
folle je sais pas si elle marchera
autant
je vais te dire à combien elle est de
vue ça a pas repris pour le moment quand
tu parti voir ça reprend
j'ai un problème de code c'est pour ça
que ça reprend pas sinon j'avais repris
automatique
c'est quoi alors attends est-ce que
ouais ça a repris j'ai juste eu un petit
bug
et lequel tu peux venir combien de temps
il a joué attends
tu connais pas
en 28 secondes
ce que je donne des cours bah oui c'est
un peu mon métier mais
j'en donne moins la j'essaie d'en donner
moins
alors je vais pouvoir recadrer les
chaînes ma chaîne attends moi j'ai pas
de chaîne Youtube si vous voulez voir
mes vidéos c'est sur la chaîne de
bitstream la chaîne principale et sinon
elle a blessé me rediff ou des fois il y
a des bougies suis ici et sinon distrib
facile j'y suis jamais mais c'est pas
mal
les caméras ont été déplacées
[Musique]
dans quel à l'écran vous voyez
qui voit à l'écran
c'est juste que tu es décalé
au début tu me vois bien et la fin tu
vois que vous quand je joue en match
Contenders tu vois que mon front à la
fin
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il a problème de
connexion
Erika ici il vient de faire
ouais il est peut-être déco mais moi
aussi j'ai eu un petit problème de
connexion
ça serait sympa là
mais d'ailleurs c'en est où maman je
sais qu'il y avait des problèmes
ils ont réglé ou pas ça va pas
c'est ça serait que ça se dérègle je
sais pas mais ça j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont fait une queue pour rentrer
qui fait qu'une fois que tu as réussi à
te connecter tu es pas mal
ah ok je viens de comprendre
ah tu es mal compris la phrase
avec ce cavalier 4 ou 2 c'est dommage
qu'il est un peu jeté la partie
précédente et qu'il est pas pris nul
quand il va tenir
est-ce que ce n'est pas je sais que
c'est une vieille
question mais est-ce que c'est pas
chiant je veux tout le temps les mêmes
si mais là honnêtement surtout avec le
dernier tournoi on a bien vu il y a il y
a plus de nouveaux joueurs
complètement ouais
une belle petite tête ce gosse mais il
faut trouver son âge pas facile
d'après Mazo il y a une petite
problème à la pesée je t'avais raconté
non il joue contre
Damien du championnat du monde il joue
contre Timothée le français que
j'entraînais et ben
il m'en dit à l'autre avait 8008 ou
quasiment mais il avait déjà de la
moustache
mais bon il a il s'est fait retourner
malheureusement
c'est beau joueur
le plus doué de
de des joueurs qui montent il faudra
qu'il confirme évidemment ouais bon ça
te ref qu'on fasse du style pas dégueu
il fatigant mais il est toujours là elle
a 3 ans de plus après
après voilà
il y a une interview il parle de ça il
dit mais progrès entre 16 et 18 ans
c'était énorme donc ouais
les plus jeunes et surtout il a l'air
d'aimer vraiment jouer et les échecs
qui est
nécessaire pas forcément suffisant mais
nécessaire ce qui a l'air d'être un peu
compliqué là pour aller raisin donne
l'impression de d'avoir découvert
d'autres plaisirs de la vie
non mais tu rigoles mais c'est
le défaut d'avoir pris Vlad comme
entraîneur
ça peut être complexe à cet âge à ses
âges-là tu peux découvrir que tu as
d'autres passions non mais sans trop les
passions je pense pas
ça se voit pas encore
il a peut-être une copine qui aime la
mode
il a fait découvrir une nouvelle passion
une carrière
alors le score c'est 2-0 s'écrit 1 0 à
mon affiché sur mon écran je pourrais
peut-être trouver un endroit pour
l'afficher mais je sais pas où
tu vas faire un petit je vais je sais
comment je vais faire attendez et Meetup
c'est une application de rencontre pour
rien à voir et je sais pas me tape ce
que c'est j'espère que ces rencontres
mais je pense pas à Meetup ça a l'air
plus des trucs de réunion
[Musique]
je sais pas faut leur laisser le temps
en fait ça sert à rien on va dire un
truc c'est la semaine d'après ça va
changer
faut leur laisser le temps quel joueur
tu parles Prague pas tous ces jeunes
faut leur laisser même Arjun il a fait
un très mauvais tournoi l'autre jour
mais bon faut pas l'enterrer sur là il
met de 0 au numéro 3 mondial
c'est un peu différent quand même
l'impression qu'il est en train de
connexion
il est agité
la mer Noire
en tout cas j'ai mis les scores ouais
franchement belle effort
ah ça y est il a vraiment très vague
comme entraîneur Mathieu
non mais là il a une bonne position
très bizarre
c'est quoi le mental c'est égal ça me
paraît clair que les blancs sont mieux
parce que le pion
C va être faible ou plombé souvent ce
que tu fais avec vous
ces cas ça va être une faiblesse parce
que tu as pas vraiment quoi assise
j'aurais été 5
est à le roi qui peut être faible 115
noir le fouger 2 qui est quand même sur
une diagonale sympa après les îles
peut-être avec H4
H4 y est pas pensé mais genre fou F5
tu peux pas
ouais
réfléchit bon et là il a raison de
réfléchir
tout à l'heure il gère pas bien leur
temps aussi les deux on trouve A3 3
c'est pas bête c'est logique quoi j'aime
bien j'aime bien
à moins qu'il faut F5 il faut F5
cavalier H4
si on prend cavalier C2 et tu peux pas
monter
à l'enfer
ouais c'est ce qu'il a joué bon bah
c'est 3R
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
mais du coup AB il faut 4 ça a été un
faveur des noirs
complexe
on dit ouais ça peut arriver d'avoir un
jour sans comme au tennis ouais mais le
problème c'est que c'est élimination
mondiale non
tu es tranquille
mais là autant la première partie il
avait pas l'air à fond là il a l'air
normal
après il est peut-être pas dedans
on sait pas en fait
c'est quoi
c'est une armoire ou une porte une porte
non pas claire
ça a l'air d'être porte quand même
mais derrière du coup il y a un défaut
avec Team c'est que tu vois ce côté
micro encastré on pourrait l'enlever
mais là pour avoir le truc bien cadré
comme il faut on est un peu obligé de
laisser comme ça
allez
nos amis
nous on fait comme on peut on a déjà eu
quelques assez de soucis on essaie de
bien cadrer comme on pouvait alors
Magnus est déjà
proche de gagnant d'ailleurs c'est quoi
on dirait une ravagine
ah oui
[Musique]
il est un peu mieux
il va faire nul il va gagner son match
il va arrêter
facile
il a joué Camille H4
du match en fait
bah
après il tente à mon avis qui avait les
H4 parce que si il le fait pas il va
faire nul et
ce qu'il a vu ça donne les quatre en
fait
trois petits tours et puis s'en va il
sera encore à demain dans le loser
bracket en B1 tu perds tes pions CB
c'est ça tourne 4 dame de 4 comment ça
marche la ligne 4
x 4 et
qui prend un train tu perds toutes et
puis c'est terminé et puis en plus il
doit il doit il doit gagner encore deux
parties torrent c'est promis
tu es complètement foutu en fait tu peux
rien faire
il a voulu risquer je pense et se dire
on sait jamais si le joue pas
ce qu'il était en obligation de gagner
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il a pas de
gros temps prévu bientôt
parce que là c'est fin d'année 4 je l'ai
trouvé c'est pas bon signe pour lui
quand même ouais après il s'est quand
même qualifié il fallait y arriver
jusqu'au top 6
il a fait le tournoi vers le haut ouais
il a il a il a été il a été assez facile
mais Riga ici c'est très fort
il a quand même pas
pas si mal joué le joueur indien
[Musique]
est parti intéressante par la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on va sûrement avoir
deux fois à mon avis Naka contre Carlson
dans ce tournoi voilà avoir une fois
dans le bracket normal puis à mon avis
celui qui perd leur match l'un contre
l'autre il va se retrouver dans le loser
bracket et revenir pour refaire un aka
Carlson
est-ce que tu veux les résultats du
groupe B vas-y un dis-nous un petit peu
Mathieu
Prague a battu tabac tabac
goussain 9 a battu girof
prana
c'est n'importe quoi
il y a du beau monde quand même
c'est le circuit a le plus d'argent et
tu joues chez toi donc c'est normal
est en train de
parler c'est qualifié mais eux ils ont
déjà enchaînés il y a moins de parties
il y a une ronde d'après ils sont déjà
en 16e allez ça marche pas du tout
pareil en fait ça se peut ouais que la
division de marche pas tout à fait
pareil
je suis en Division 3
Division 2
divisions de népaux a battu le pichottes
double contre Kravitz Lenny c'est
égalité
you en train de battre sa douanier mais
c'est ok c'est chaud
Kramnik qui a perdu contre Salem
et caroanna a gagné
C2 échecs à mon avis
C2 et cavaliers ça a l'air de passer
fort
et quand tu me fais fou prendre B5 je
fais juste soit je donne la qualité
genre qui est en B3
qui est promettement
de plus il y a des deux faibles
on dit le fameux Théo deux roues assez
auto
un petit peu c'est les deux trois
comiques du chat
mais il en faut
ok bah il y a qu'un match intéressant en
fait
c'est
pas notre
on va attendre que ça se finisse
malheureusement les amis pour cette
première journée c'est vrai qu'on
pouvait pas connaître pire spectacle
côté français notre joueur qui a qui a
complètement explosé
la partie aux candidats où il fait un
commentaire d'avoir fait partie je
pensais être mieux en fait il avait pas
du tout compris la pose
là j'ai l'impression qu'il réfléchit
trop tard
des fois tu te sens pas les moments où
tu dois vraiment calculer après quand tu
es né de zéro que tu es que tu es dos
mur
pour du bien il y a quoi tu as le choix
d'en prendre un j'aime bien
ça peut arriver mais pas dans les médias
mais ça peut
si à champion du monde je pense que ça
pourrait intéresser Carson
ce que je fais des simultané oui et j'en
trouve mais ça c'est rare
malheureusement j'aime bien j'en ai fini
à 2 semaines mais normalement j'en fais
pas trop deux ou trois
en plus c'est
on avait regardé
c'est assez facile
terrible
il fait quel d'abord est-ce que ça
change quelque chose
du coup c'est plus malin ça force
et prend à 3 c'est la position qu'on
aille tout à l'heure mais oui c'est
complètement gagnant
parce qu'à la fin en fait parce que tu
peux pas arrêter le purin
la poule perdante pour la gagner et
arriver plein de confiance en finale
contre Magnus Wiko
donc là BK
on prend et quand tu bouges le fou à
deux non après il faut à 8 km3 voilà
c'est la même en fait en vrai
3 prises et tu te menaces reprend à 8
ouais je peux prendre un 8 si tu bouges
le fou je faisais
tout est gagnant c'est trop facile
voilà c'est la partie c'est la variante
qu'on avait montré il y a déjà une
dizaine de minutes
deuxième minute plus une minute trente
c'est une triste pollution à la partie
était d'une tristesse aujourd'hui ouais
mais là la pause elle a pleuré est-ce
que je peux jouer
pareil
en fait
c'est plus professionnel
il y a un tableau ce sera la finale du
Winner Bracket
c'est bien ça donc en fait celui qui
perd ce match là repart en loser bracket
joue un match jeudi le gagne
probablement et revient en finale
vendredi
c'est pas mal comme système je l'ai
jamais vu qu'aux échecs mais ça existe
en jeu vidéo ça existe la seule
difficulté de ça c'est que du coup le
mec qui pète ouais en fait du coup c'est
un double élimination ça a déjà exauce
échecs il y avait World chef qui avait
fait ça pour c'était une émission Russie
qui avait appelé Armageddon et ça joue
exactement sur ce système le seul
problème qui avait eu dans le système là
c'est qu'en fait du coup très souvent la
finale c'est un remake de la finale du
Winner Bracket
et donc si le gars regagne c'est l'autre
gars qui gagne en finale du coup il y a
une troisième finale entre les deux
joueurs
c'est génial
défaut en fait ouais mais ça paraît
logique que le mec gameporn en faisant
un non mais ça c'est normal mais c'est
pour ça que souvent quand ils font ça
dans les jeux vidéo c'est des tableaux
qui sont plus grands et du coup tu
remontes pas jusqu'à la fin dans Louis
Nord bracket
[Musique]
c'est rare d'avoir deux mecs vraiment au
dessus du lot comme là peut-être
disons qu'en fait à un moment donné si
c'est les tournois commencent en 32e de
finale et à partir de du quart de finale
en fait le tableau il est fermé entre
guillemets
je suis d'accord avec toi c'est un peu
bizarre mais
il paraît pas motivé filou mais en fait
la première ouais mais après je trouve
que ça allait mieux on l'a pas vu
[Musique]
ok après normal pour Magnus qualifier il
t'a plus 6 ouais c'est pas embêté
qui est pas bien
ok
c'est un peu compliqué à faire donc on
va regarder la fin comme ça
ça marche alors pourquoi il est en
danger parce qu'en fait il bouge pas
pendant les trois c'est c'est l'enfer et
tu menaces des faux F4
d'un point F4 D2 et des trucs comme ça
genre
ça marche pas
tu as compris ce que je veux dire tu
peux avoir tu sais ce que tu peux
menacer de beau on va pas y arriver mais
c'est pour montrer c'est Dame des 4 vous
prendrez trois pions et damasutemat
on peut y arriver mais non mais c'est
joli
non je pense
je vais mettre comme à côté s'il y a un
coup un blender
j'y crois pas trop
il a enfin fait à 5 bon il a pas de
temps avec le Pione mais il a fait à
quoi
il a joué une ligne qui est intéressante
je veux montrer c'est ce qu'il avait
joué à la première c'est un truc
complètement concret alors Magnus la
jouer une fois
ça paraît complètement con parce que tu
pas du matériel mais en fait ce service
de qualité il est intéressant Magnus le
déjà joué
et même l'ordi dit avantage mais en fait
un rapide c'est pas bête très bien joué
j'ai 4 tu as vu
A6 ah si c'est professionnel
[Musique]
touche la tour la Punta
et il y a pas de perpète avec la non en
plus
c'est chèque derrière Naka qui a l'air
très content sur la caméra je vois le
retour
ça doit être en train de se qualifier
qu'auta américain
et Raouf donc qui rencontre qualifié
Naka
c'est c'est la partie de tableau du
carreau
il joue dame
qui prépare fou des quatre en réalité
bah c'est très con non
je vois pas de prise prise
fout des quatre tours prise prise G5
vous allez voir mais en gros il veut ça
désolé je suis allé un couple plus vite
dans la variante ça
G3 il est revenu en dessin qui est
cavalier F1
après il peut se dire aussi que
s'il a pas beaucoup d'avant il va pas le
faire maintenant en fait parce qu'ils
ont dû voir un truc sur dame 3
trois fous prendre des un roi fouger un
roi franc et je suis mieux avec les
Blancs fait trois F2
Dame des 6
tu es toujours pas bien
ici c'est toujours la crise - 5 - 4
mais il a pas vu tout à l'heure il va
pas le trouver
à 3 peut-être mais maintenant qui avait
dû au 3
tu le laisses un peu respirer
peut-être pas trop parce que quand tu
feras fou des quatre tours il y aura fou
ces trois mais bon s'éloigne trop
selon l'ordi dans la partie de la
réserver après c'était pas perdu du tout
non mais c'est caviage 4 qui a un coup
pourri ce qu'on a dit le truc c'est
qu'après à 3 du coup si tu fais le coup
qu'il faut c'est à dire après en B4 il
faut prendre 4 tu as plus aucun avantage
j'étais obligé de gagner et en fait
c'était son idée mais juste ça marchait
pas à cause d'emmener 4
RIP
c'est pas un c'est pas deux c'est 3 et
là sur foot4 il veut quoi j'ai pas la
ref moi j'ai pas la réponse encore
j'ai pas
on va voir si
ils ont des caméras ils sont ils doivent
une derrière une devant ils ont quoi
comme le son ouvert peut-être qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont comme mesure
son verre de caméra j'arrive pas à avoir
deux angles
mais en général enfin je sais pas ce que
tu en penses d'ailleurs dans ça mais moi
c'est plutôt mon avis je pense que si ça
a triche est plus dans les califes que
dans les tournois
dans les califes c'est évident mais
parce qu'en fait le mec il va se prendre
déjà un billet là il a plus là il est
vachement plus checker
ouais bon après non moi je pense que
c'est partout mais
je vois pas pourquoi ne pas le faire en
fait si tu peux pourquoi ne pas faire
si tu as un système si tu as un système
qui est pas détectable si tu veux je
vois pas pourquoi ne pas le faire c'est
dommage
comment ça marche la prise prise est-ce
que tu fais pousser trois cavaliers 3 il
faut prendre des cartes je pense que moi
intuitivement c'est ce que j'aurais fait
j'aurais pas les prendre en G1 j'aurais
fait pousser trois fous prends B4 perso
intuitivement ça je pense que c'est
gagnant
on va voir ça va être la partie
probablement
l'ordi confirme pas du tout ce que je
dis mais lui il fait roi fuite alors ça
c'est bizarre
il va peut-être se prendre G4 h4h
j'aurais pas fait ça
il peut même la perdre avec les noirs
4 et cavaliers F3 échec H5 il va te
prendre le pion passé s'éloigné va la
perdre complètement
il a oublié
[Musique]
H6 ça c'est sûr que c'est gagnant
cavalier 5 et terrible
on vous a dit que c'était la partie
intéressante
pour apprendre des trois et ça va
tourner pour pour Wesley
mais bon même en vrai partie le
micro-oreillette ça peut te suffire pour
gagner donc ouais sauf tu prends un
risque en là tu prends pas de risque en
plus de risques
il y a plein de moyens en vrai il y a
plein de moyens
de mettre une petite pub attend on va
laisser la fin de la partie Mathieu
cavalier qui va arriver en F6 c'est pas
encore complètement terminé
il est à Toronto
il est chez les bras il
doit pas être bien
je pense franchement
il est cool
on
faire cavalier F6 roi et F8 et puis il
va Rav naviguer le cavalier en dessin
bref 7 c'est tellement gagnant facile il
y a même pas
cavalier aussi c'est bien aussi
le 5 pardon c'est bien aussi
parce que j'ai fait j'ai pas de partie
nul donc voilà donc pas de surprise
c'est bizarre qui trouve pas ce que tu
as dit en fait il fait un autre truc
bien il fait fou B3 qui prend F7 et
surtout F7 il arrive cet échec
et il gagne la finale de pion facile
alors question très importante oui ce
sont vos vrais chat à lui la photo de
profil
un peu contre les cours du jeu ouais
parce qu'il s'est fait dominer
clairement
ok donc
petite pub petite pub petite pub Mathieu
[Musique]
il est pas bien donc on va vous mettre
une petite pause on va faire une toute
petite pause et on va être de retour
pour la dernière partie de saut contre
ma méthode dans une petite dizaine de
minutes donc nous on sera de retour à
vers 19h30 je pense entre 19h30 et 19h35
à tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs ça a repris un peu
plus tôt qu'on ne le pensait
on n'était pas je pensais que c'était 35
on était pas sur les horaires correctes
après on a pas raté grand chose puisque
c'est qu'une italienne entre guillemets
e4-5f3 qui est ici ou C4 ou c'est 5 D6
d3c3 et le qui a bougé hyper solide
attends il faut que je recoudre les
caméras parce que ça retouche changer
entre temps là tu vas bien avec des
joueurs qui sont des joueurs qui sont
partis arriver
mais ne vous inquiétez pas mesdames et
messieurs
ça va arriver
c'est complexe à faire à chaque fois
bah ouais mais surtout que là je sais
pas pourquoi ça me les met différemment
c'est un peu chiant
le fait qu'il soit plus que deux dans la
conversation etc bon je vais faire comme
ça sinon on va pas y arriver ils sont
ultrasons
désolé mesdames et messieurs on fait ce
qu'on peut
de toute façon c'est une italienne pour
le moment il y a pas de
il y a pas de dingue
et donc les scores
une enquête
[Musique]
et les joueurs
c'est sa
tu mets ouf non
elle est pas exactement comme il faut
ah mais en fait c'est lui qui est pas en
face de sa caméra ok il m'a induit en
erreur en fait
écoute on va le mettre comme ça c'est la
dernière partie du jour c'est pas
évident de faire mieux
parce qu'il est ultra zoomé en fait il
est complètement dessus on peu importe
donc ces petits italiens et il a besoin
que du nul
Rohff il va jouer à l'ancienne il va je
pense pour G4 je le vois bien par OK
faire un petit olline et la paire
il a de toute façon ça change rien
rien ne change
non c'était pas ma Médée
en plus on en sait beaucoup plus que ce
que les gens savent donc c'est complexe
beaucoup trop moi j'en sais trop
il faudrait mieux en savoir moins
comme dit un philosophe qui peut pas
parler sinon tu auras des problèmes ok
oui non non il vaut mieux pas savoir il
vaut mieux pas trop savoir mais là pour
le châssis ça va être sympa par contre
ça va être
ça commence bientôt normalement je vous
le on n'a pas les dates moi j'ai du mal
à me LP
mais les dates tu les auras dernier
moment Mathieu parce que c'est une
compétition ou tu investis de l'argent
il y a beaucoup de monde donc c'est pas
logique de donner les dates même un mois
à l'avance
tu les auras dernière minute les dates
Mathieu faut que tu t'habitues il faut
que tu rentres dans le tempo
t'es pas dans le tempo en fait
j'aime bien tes prévoir les choses
si tu joues le 16 en fait et tu auras
tes points bonus qui vont tomber et tu
dois être bien avec le bonus
et démantè tu la sens comment alors
remonter comme une pendule
ça manque de confiance là mais au moins
être intéressant aux échecs c'est quand
même un bon début mais tu sens qu'elle
va nous mettre des puntos ou pas
c'est hyper dur non c'est pas
franchement si elle fait un sur quatre
elle aura réussi son match je te le dis
très franchement entre toi une partie
jouable à chaque fois c'est ça trois
deux très dur elle va en avoir deux
casiers impossibles une très dure et une
jouable en gros
la foi pour que tu joues pour mieux tu
fais honte bah ouais mais bon si tu fais
un tu fais un supermarché
si tu fais zéro tu fais un match de
merde en fait tu joues tout sur une
partie mais le truc c'est qu'il faut pas
être trop impacté par les trois
premières psychologiquement
après elle est tellement bien payée
qu'elle va le faire
non mais tu sais qu'on va gagner un peu
d'argent là cette année
si on gagne des trucs
si on se qualifie si on gagne des trucs
et on se connait les équipes parce que
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des matchs de
calife l'autre jour alors nous on est
qualifié mais les autres équipes pour te
dire je suis pas allé je suis pas allé
chercher de toute façon c'est pas contre
qui on joue donc on verra bien
s'il y a des petites équipes sympas
on fait rien
il y aura pas d'équipe facile
ce que je peux dire c'est qu'il y aura
aucun match facile cette année mais
vraiment aucun en fait
c'est quoi la moyenne comment ça marche
25,50 la moyenne et l'eau donc ça sera
la prochaine qui commence sur chesscom
alors la date de début officielle je
crois pas en disant que c'est
alors est-ce que c'est 14 ou le 13
non on est censé jouer le 16 ou le 17
entre 16h et 20 heures
le début du match c'est pour ça que je
te dis je peux pas te dire concept parce
que là à la fourchette est trop grande
non mais surtout est-ce que de monter là
elle est pas là le 17 elle peut pas le
16 elle peut
quelle heure tu as dit
normalement 16 30 ou 20 à 18h j'ai un
truc faut que je décale
je te dirai quand je quand je sais et
mais le
vendredi elle part en elle est pas à
Bordeaux le 17 à papa c'est sûr on aura
un forfait c'est pas grave j'aurais dit
c'est impossible en fait on peut pas
faire autrement
tu peux pas prévoir 40 millions de
joueurs et avoir des dates 4 jours avant
non mais c'est pas la faute de démonter
c'est pas la mienne c'est pas la faute
de Katia en fait c'est pas possible en
fait
elle peut moi faut que je décale un truc
ça va
ouais mais même ça dure combien de temps
ah c'est 10 + 2 ça doit durer deux
heures max
non mais genre je peux décaler mon cours
à 18h c'est juste est-ce que c'est une
semaine on a ah non on n'a pas la petite
Victoria ah oui non non va être le 16 il
y a zéro problème sur ce qu'on a pas
notre fille
c'est les vacances scolaires ici tu me
fais peur là
ces vacances scolaires
c'est vacances pour les parents les
vacances scolaires en fait bah pas du
tout parce que là cette semaine on a
rien prévu du coup elle est avec la
semaine avec nous donc quand je fais une
vidéo
elle a la petite et vice-versa
en tout cas moi moi je leur ai déjà
écrit je leur ai écrit que si nous
faisons un vendredi en dernière minute
on aurait un tas de forfait et là de
façon ce sera le cas le vendredi
généralement nous c'est problématiques
d'après elle est pas là non plus le
vendredi mais le jeudi oui c'est ce que
je leur ai dit mais en fait c'est pas la
seule qui est dans ce cas-là donc en
fait si ça tombe des vendredi on va
faire on aura des matchs on sera full
forfait
tablette en février il y a tous les
week-ends
[Musique]
je sais pas qui est dans notre équipe
mais pour les mecs comme moi pour me
faire jouer en ligne
je vais lui réécrire désolé désolé les
amis là cette partie est pas
passionnante honnêtement
peut-être qu'il peut essayer de pousser
un peu ça mais j'y crois pas trop
et Costeux qui va sauver
allez elle est en feu
la raison en profiter
ça va faire nul sans trop d'effort pour
Wesley
6 ou 5 ton rêve D8 qui est 5 prix ce qui
est français 4
ça doit aller
86 je reprends la tour
c'est pas
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on est tombé sur
la pire journée possible honnêtement
parce que les trois autres matchs c'est
3-0 il se passe rien enfin ok c'est
juste trop sens unique et la dernière le
dernier match serré c'est la serrure
soit avec les noirs qui fait nul sans
forcer dans la partie face absolument
rien
c'est ouais c'est pas
intéressant c'est quand il arnaqué la
partie d'avant d'ailleurs
on est tombé sur le seul moment
intéressant de la journée on pourra s'en
féliciter
on le voit vraiment pas sur la caméra ou
alors
attends je vais essayer de faire un truc
ou alors c'est TIMS qui me l'aimait
bizarrement et qui me fait une caméra
qui est je vais tenter un truc
ah ouais ok non bah ils sont hyper
zoomer mais si tu as grandi team il est
centre un peu mieux
mais on pourra pas faire beaucoup mieux
que ça donc je vais laisser comme ça
pour le moment
complexe
et on n'a pas la qualité de leur air en
plus
la quoi la qualité de l'horaire
et c'est vrai que c'est con parce que
les horaires
les horaires de la prochaine sigues un
peu compliqué parce qu'en fait
c'est pas des horaires fixes je sais pas
trop comment ils font leur truc
mais ils le savent pas eux-mêmes non
mais en fait ouais je sais pas pourquoi
ils évitent pas le vendredi globalement
parce que le vendredi c'est forcément un
jour problématique s'ils veulent jouer
dernier moment pour tout le monde en
fait
parce que c'est un jour de voyage en
fait logiquement il devrait éviter le
vendredi et lundi les gens d'aller en
lundi avale le soir
jouer mardi mercredi jeudi c'est quand
même les jours où tu as le moins de
problèmes
non mais les autres jours ça va être
mieux les matchs vont être beaucoup plus
serrés ça va être nettement plus
intéressant dès demain
bah demain c'est demi
qui est plutôt un quart
du coup
dans le sens où tu as trois matchs à
gagner encore
en tout cas ça aura pas jouer très
longtemps on est que on est même pas 3h
de jeu encore même on est même à 2h et
demi ça avait commencé un peu en retard
on va quand même noter trois heures
[Musique]
et demi mais
là
franchement il se passe rien en fait les
amis c'est pas pas de la mauvaise
volonté ça me fait penser au match de
rugby que j'ai regardé hier soir j'ai
regardé
Stade Français Bordeaux Bègles et les
commentateurs
c'est beau bon bah on est tombé sur un
mauvais match enfin ils étaient ils
étaient dégoûté il se passait rien
j'étais dans le train que je dois à
Paris ce weekend et j'y suis allé
vendredi
et j'étais en première avec toute
l'équipe du stade
quelque chose
ça paraît bizarre ouais mais parfois
il avait des écoutes attends il avait
des écouteurs dans les oreilles qu'il a
enlevé
j'ai pas rêvé on est d'accord les gars
je sais pas si quelqu'un d'autre
regardait la cam je peux pas voir quand
je suis en partageant
tu vas pouvoir le voir avec le décalage
j'ai mis regarde bien ouais donc alors
tous les jours du bébé et ça part lit
regarder le rugby en direct puisqu'il y
avait des matchs il y avait un Top 14 il
y avait regarde la cam pour voir les
écouteurs
bah oui il a un fil annoncé les lunettes
Asté les lunettes alors c'est pas les
écouteurs
et eux ils ont un zoom où ils ont un
petit
traits
je vais être mal
et donc du coup un moment moi je regarde
série où je me prépare je fais des trucs
et maintenant j'entends le bruit de
cheeseccom
il y en a un qui joue j'ose pas rien
dire toi quand je faisais des échecs
j'espère que quelqu'un me parle d'homme
j'ai pas osé parler parce que Mazo il
m'a dit mais parle il y a mon voisin
c'est mon pote posé et en sortant mais
il y en a un qui est en train de jouer
sur chaise comme un mec de l'UBB et tu
sais pas qui
j'ai pas reconnu en plus moi j'ai connu
vraiment rien
il a vraiment enlevé des écouteurs mais
alors c'est quoi les
si tu peux avoir des écouteurs dans les
oreilles c'est quoi le
mais d'ailleurs il a enlevé il a joué un
mauvais coup avant non
ouais non mais bon je comprends pas en
fait c'est qu'est-ce qui vérifie en fait
ça le droit d'avoir des écouteurs dans
les oreilles je comprends pas ce que
c'est les mesures pour sortir ou pas en
fait
c'est super des écouteurs c'est quand
même
je sais pas trop comment ça fonctionne
de toute façon c'est impossible
d'empêcher donc oui tu peux aussi partir
du principe que ça va mais les écouteurs
c'est c'est étonnant tu vois sa caméra
derrière sur l'autre sur notre télé
et il a fait un clip pour essayer
l'écouteur
S
mais ça marche pas comme ça
alors là quitte qui te dit que le mec
est pas connecté en Bluetooth avec
quelqu'un je sais pas trop d'oreilles
avec
[Musique]
des fils
pas probable
ça peut après que ce soit juste des
bouchons d'oreille mais
bon allez voir sur une caméra si t'as
pas fait fabriquer des écouteurs qui
ressemblent à des bouchons d'oreille
il y a ce côté amateur quand même dans
les déchets encore qui est assez pénible
ah ouais quand tu mets 2 millions
d'euros sur la blotta
ouais c'est mais un million 9
et fait quelque chose de plus propre
déjà que les mecs ils sont capables de
se mettre des trucs dans le fion
avec même pas les oreilles non mais tu
vois
ouais c'est un peu particulier
maintenant il y a laissé des chances de
guerre non tu peux me mettre le 1 2
faire H4 ouais il est un peu mieux ouais
c'est tellement con ça va buter
[Musique]
ensemble plus avec des bouchons des fils
avec des fils ouais mais bon enfin
on va pas aller chercher à comprendre
c'est juste pas le droit tu as pas le
droit déjà mais d'ailleurs même sur les
lunettes sur les sur les sur les tiges
de lunettes tu pourras voir un truc
caché qui te permet d'entendre les
lunettes devraient être interdite aussi
et forcer les
les lentilles
tu avais vu l'image de ce quand il joue
il a l'écran tout petit il a un immense
écran d'ordi et quand il fait du Blitz
il rétrécit mais il a raison je pense
que c'est plutôt bien Baki le feu aussi
et j'avais pas pensé quand j'ai vu je
veux dire ça c'est pas con du tout
en tout cas il est pas bien il y a l'air
sur l'autre
c'est peut-être la qualité de leur
studio
on m'a dit que je pouvais partager la
qualité de l'air de chez moi si je
voulais pendant les lives mais bon je
dis que c'était pas
j'avais pas très envie quoi
ça te fait marrer
bah pour moi si de connaître la qualité
de mon air c'est utile
je parle pour les auditeurs pour qui
sache avec quel air on fait des
commentaires d'une telle qualité
à chaque fois que je finis un stream
démonter me dit ouvre la fenêtre ça pue
c'est un autre type de détecteur
non mais la chaleur
l'homme
bouteille de son père ça me
[Musique]
avec la petite ouverture de santé
tranquille
et il te tape là et là je pense
on voit qui pour gagner le tournoi à moi
je vais faire je vais essayer de s'en
prendre tout le monde je veux dire car
seul Wiko
[Musique]
le battre ouais en plus de truc qui est
marrant c'est que les joueurs qui
pourraient avoir plus de chance contre
eux genre en ce moment ceux qui sont un
peu en pleine bourre Guy Abdou en fait
il privilégie vraiment le circuit
réel pour essayer d'aller chercher le
titre de champion du monde et d'ailleurs
c'est aussi logique comme quand ça
t'intéresse plus tu joues mieux
du coup les joueurs qui pourraient
vraiment les gêner les deux trois qui
pourraient les gêner
[Musique]
mais même si roux on sent qu'il vous
faut
le problème c'est qu'il se concentre
consacre à rien là
après honnêtement j'espère me tromper
ça me paraît bizarre d'avoir laissé le
pion H4 là non
ouais après c'est pas facile de jouer le
gars avec les Blancs honnêtement
3 minutes contre
ça parle de la veste de neiman
allô papa tango
ouais la partie en plus elle est hyper
bizarre je comprends pas grand chose et
il a donné un pion je n'ai pas compris
pourquoi
qui joue pour le gain ben je sais pas si
les blancs mais au niveau de la position
je suis pas sûr
après c'était pas facile à gérer ce pion
de plus
et du coup est-ce que tu peux dire qui
on a on est en proches League ou pas
faire une annonce vous n'êtes pas le
moment et l'endroit quoi
je suis curieux
mais je vois les choses m'intéressent
c'est pas c'est pas pour meubler
non mais en fait
franchement je me rappelle plus ce que
tu
sais un fort c'est tout non et une ouais
mais en fait c'est tout ce qu'il y a à
savoir
et dans les Français je sais pas
toujours les mêmes
les deux
et tu as pris un jeune c'est ça
et deux jeunes Maëlle et junior
junior tu comprends qui c'est junior
si tu as le Père tu as le fils
je ne comprends rien
pas de surprise
on peut difficilement faire mieux
bon j'espère pouvoir prendre Timothée
mais il a deux points et l'autre trop
pour rentrer dans les compos c'est
dommage
je trouve ça
il est fort
il est vraiment bon c'est un peu le il
est un peu mon style jeune je pense
il a pas une il a une petite culture
mais pas énorme les ouvertures ils
connaissaient ces trucs ça me fait
penser un peu à moi je
et à l'époque je veux que des attaques
anglaises je le connais pour toi et il
base beaucoup de choses sur le calcul
on a eu le même premier entraîneur en
plus c'est pour ça que j'y pense
c'est beau joueur
ou du monde
mais il aurait il était pas loin de
pas hyper la partie importante contre
Justin mais il était malade non
non
[Musique]
bon ok c'est intéressant et attaque le
cavalier F6 il veut bouffer un 5
ça doit pas vraiment marcher mais ok
c'est non je pense c'est bien joué c'est
un bon essai mais ça doit pas marcher
heureux 5 et 17
[Musique]
là ça marche pas du tout non
tu vas pas gagner hein
mais si joue comme ça il pourra revenir
dans le tableau et mamedov
c'est pas un cadeau non plus là il peut
prendre un schiste recette il y aura 7
il peut aussi faire cavalier
ouais ben Mathieu la montagne a couché
d'une souris aujourd'hui il y aura pas
eu la moindre belle partie à se mettre
sous la dent en réalité
une de Magnus je pense moi on l'a pas vu
ouais enfin dans ce que nous on dans la
partie tournoi qu'on suivait on est on
est très mal tombé il y a eu la fin
ouais la fin de partie de fin de
qui était intéressante et la fin de
Somme à Médor quand il est perdant et
qui gagne ça c'était comme ça
des trucs de fou
ok mais ça arrive après c'est le premier
jour
de ce tournoi faut lancer les choses
après c'est même pas sûr que ça soit
perdant mais en fait il a besoin de
gagner pour le
pour le match donc
on y croit pas
il est obligé de gagner il va pas y
arriver
qui est le 5 et 3
e
question à la tour en premier
parce que c'est un intérêt
dans tous les cas la tour va se décaler
littéralement non
ils sont coiffés
je vois bien ma Médor fait que la coupe
de Julien son
y
dessin au prochain
inintéressant
aujourd'hui c'est complexe
en revanche 4 en plus
il est nettement moins fort il a
peut-être 100 points à l'eau de moins
10 ans de plus
elle prend cette quelque chose
non non
il a pièce de plus il a besoin de faire
nul il va faire ce que j'avais dit
il y aura peut-être un roi F4 ambulant
mais qui dit qu'il y a des cartes
tourage 6 mat
il faut espérer roi je crois
il touche le roi il doit le jouer pas de
chance
ah c'est très pétition
de plus
il a l'air un peu dégoûté bizarrement
incroyable
les points et l'eau
et c'est marrant parce qu'il le fait pas
pour ses points et l'eau réels
normalement ça
il a l'air d'avoir envie de la gagner
mais je comprends pas pourquoi
c'est terrible
il a pris 3 euros
la vibrante
il y a bien deux un dans le match c'est
écrit le score et écrit
ils ont poussé
il respecte vraiment pas
non en plus il y a vraiment de bonne
chance de nulle en pratique parce que tu
perds ces 6 c'est déjà nul ton roi est
enfermé
techniquement gagnant
bah non mais puis en plus tu as gagné le
match ça plus qu'à faire nul c'est
bizarre en fait
il a encore les écouteurs
avec des fils
quand tu es chez toi tu mets les
bouchons toi
mais
c'est le même échec en vient
pour une rapide là ça sert à rien je
sais pas pourquoi il joue moi j'aimerais
bien qu'il tombe
il prend enfin je sais pas pourquoi il
fait ça
[Musique]
non mais ça gagne pas mais ça me dépasse
de laisser des trucs pareil
tu gères c'est pas si clair en fait
il peut tomber
bien sûr
c'est pas c'est maintenant
tu l'arrêtes facilement le Punto
c'est incroyable à ce qui fait j'ai
jamais vu ça Mathieu mais ça va tenir de
justesse
et c'est simple qui était 8 17 3G 6
[Musique]
tu peux pas la gagner roi des 6 roi
froid
je comprends pas en fait
ok donc du coup donc
du coup demain du coup ça reprend demain
il y a encore des gens qui jouent de
l'autre côté tableau mais bon on va pas
suivre les divisions qu'on comprend pas
en réalité mais il y a pas rame qui est
en train de battre zideler
ok bon j'espère que ça vous a plu je
pense que ça va monter en puissance le
tournoi très clairement ouais ce sera là
on est vraiment tombé sur vous pouvez
pas tomber sur pire quoi
et en plus demain il y aura la qualité
de ton air
non non ça je vais pas le mettre mais il
y aura
Fabien
je pourrais montrer l'appareil demain il
y aura Fab et il y aura de beaux matchs
puisque on va avoir Magnus conquérir ici
j'espère que ce sera
plus serré et Hikaru contre Wesley qui
sera obligatoirement serré je vois pas
où est-ce qu'il est
ça peut aller à l'armagnon donc on aura
des matchs bien plus intéressants
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement
c'était c'était un jour comme ça comme
il en arrive dans le sport de haut
niveau on vous remercie d'avoir suivi le
live et on vous retrouve demain et moi
je repasserai peut-être en live un peu
plus tard ce soir merci Mathieu